[Musique]
voyez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui chers ennemis bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde au nom au maire
d' bienvenus ouais je sais béton pied
alors bienvenue sur le plateau bon bien
asseyez-vous bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle
l'émission avec nous ce soir à bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
albert dubois tél les beckham
oui il fait
[Applaudissements]
jean michel cousteau
west chaplin
jean edouard lipa
[Applaudissements]
et
pascal sellem
le blind test or le blanc
regarde alors on a vu
c'est à toi thierry qui l'a acheté en
faisant un don à l'association laurette
fugain
ah oui c'est vrai il a téléphoné il m'a
dit est ce que je peux investir mille
euros pour toi à la vente aux enchères
de l'association laurette fugain et
qu'est-ce qui me rapporte pour 1000
euros baissent et ça vaut plus que ça la
chambre c'est le costume de scène de
michel sardou le costume de scène de
michel sardou
c'est sûr que c'est le sien quand on
voit la taille des jambes ya pas de
doute c'est un certificat d'authenticité
salvador at-elle chapeau d'henri
salvador toi je suis très fier et j'ai
vendu mes requêtes bagnols à claude
berri comme quoi il a prononcé sa leur
ont fait le tour des ventes aux enchères
mais comme il n'a pas trop de blé
évidemment c'est ses potes qui paye
aussi qu'est ce que tu veux que je fous
du costume de scène je veux que tu
mettes l'adresse de l'association
laurette fugain emballé s'il vous plaît
monsieur kalfon voilà un que tu met ça
en vente au profit de l'association
laurette fugain coeur donc je le revends
moi je l'achète 1000 euros et ils vont
jeunes des changements sardo donc si
vous voulez acheter
pour combien bon le mec ou noir chair on
le met aux enchères
voilà le costume de scène de michel
sardou ça devrait faire dans les dix
mille saint louis à wayne ont bien je
vais le garder comme ça toute la soirée
on sait bien que c'est bien
nos rangs la statue que tarak ben ammar
acheté dix mille euros
je pense qu'il n'ya pas d'enchère donc
on va lui adjugé à la statue au profit
de l'abbé pierre de france voilà donc
tard axa et une journée pour 10000 si tu
veux venir rechercher la semaine
enchaînant s'il veut mettre plus si peu
à peu un oui mais ça dépend je sais pas
comment marche le film la passion de
jésus christ l'a bien très bien donc il
peut mettre dix mille de plus caractère
bienvenue à la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant en slicks
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
zig bonsoir bonsoir
alors on parle français ou anglais vous
pouvez poser les questions en français
gérard pont près en anglais d'accord on
à faire des vannes en italien c'est de
loin votre fils est professeur de
littérature française vous parler
français avec lui de temps en temps
alors le monde entier attend l'êtes vous
vous êtes mondialement célèbre en slicks
puisque vous étiez le chef des
inspecteurs en désarmement de l'onu en
irak entre 2000 et 2003 vous et vos
collaborateurs étaient chargés de
trouver ces fameuses armes de
destruction massive de saddam hussein
alors vous témoigner aujourd'hui dans un
livre publié chez fayard et qui
s'intitule irak les armes
introuvable et vous avez choisi merci
tout le monde en parle pour en parler
alors je vais vous présenter rapidement
vous êtes suédois vous êtes né en 1928
vous fait quand même 76 ans plutôt
solides les suédois ça conserve
vous êtes né à uppsala vous avez une
carrière de diplomate jusqu'en 1997 et
fin 1999 vous êtes en patagonie avec
votre épouse qui est diplomate également
pour échapper aux impôts rappelons le
nom parce que son épouse eva kit est
chargé des régions arctiques
donc il était parti là-bas tous les deux
c'est sarens voilà voilà donc vous êtes
en patagonie avec votre épouse quand on
vous avertit qu'un certain monsieur
koffi et ambitieux café cherche à vous
joindre évidemment c'est kofi annan qui
vous propose le poste de inspecteur en
chef pour l'irak
alors vous vous êtes contents et à la
retraite et à stockholm avec votre femme
et vous lui dites non dans un premier
temps oui parce que j'étais bien avec ma
femme nous avons fait des excursions
oui d'un seul coup ça vous retombe sur
la tête vous dites voir plein de merde
et vous vous dites non c'est un bon
petit tour dans l'antarctique mais au
bout du compte j'ai fini par accepter
cette proposition qu en mars 2000 vous
vous retrouvez à new york dans
l'immeuble de l'onu dans votre bureau du
51e étage et trois ans plus tard un
dimanche le 16 mars 2003 toujours dans
ce petit bureau du 51e étage en slicks
vous comprenez que c'est fini les
inspecteurs rentrer les états unis ont
passé outre l'opposition du conseil de
sécurité
vous êtes dans lequel est plat ce moment
là quand vous voyez que finalement tout
votre action s'est soldée par un échec
puisque c'est la guerre j'étais déçu
parce que je pensais que quelques mois
de plus d'inspections aurait permis de
montrer que tous ces sites
les sites dont les
les états unis et les britanniques et
leurs agences de renseignements disait
qu'il contenait des armes de destruction
massive aurait fait l'objet
d'inspections et on n'aurait pas trouvé
et ça aurait montré au monde ainsi
qu'aux grands pouvoirs et aux grandes
puissances que la preuve dont il dispose
est est inadéquate
voilà il faut dire aussi qu'avec trois
cent mille hommes massés dans le désert
et l'arrivée de la saison chaude
la guerre était peut être inévitable
chaque les américains n'avaient pas
attaqué à ce moment là après ça il
fallait attendre 6 mois non oui c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque il y avait de moins
en moins de chances d'aboutir à une
solution pacifique on avait pratiquement
300 mille hommes qui attendaient dans le
désert peut-être aurait-on pu l'éviter
si quelque chose de spectaculaire s'est
produit c'est saddam hussein avait
prononcé un discours s'il avait promis
que dans les dix jours à venir il aurait
résolu les différentes questions qui se
posaient mais ça ne s'est pas passé
ainsi et les américains pénétrer et les
inspecteurs sont partis voilà alors on
ira que les soldats américains
évidemment on ne trouve pas plus d'armes
de destruction massive que vous y en
avait pas le fameux moment de vérité
dont par les bouchers powell n'a pas eu
lieu ce qui démontre l'ampleur du
mensonge parce que finalement personne
n'a trouvé jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a
toujours pas trouvé d'armes de
destruction massive en irak
on ne sait pas où elle avait dit avant
l'arrivée de la guerre que c'était le
moment de la vérité
ce serait le déclenchement de la guerre
et à ce moment là on démontrerait qu'il
y avait des arbres mais en fait la
réalité était que ce moment de vérité a
montré qu'il n'y en avait pas et n'avait
pas est ce que pour vous tony blair et
george bush sont des menteurs ou des
illuminés je pense qu'ils ont induit le
monde en erreur mais je ne pense pas
qu'ils l'ont fait délibérément je ne
dirai jamais qu'ils ont été des menteurs
il n'y a aucune preuve indiquant qu'il
savait que ce qu'il disait était erronée
au contraire
peu sont des conversations que j'ai eues
avec tony blair new j'avais le sentiment
qu'il était véritablement convaincu mais
une conviction un petit peu comme celle
des gens des siècles passés en europe
qui pensaient qu'il y avait des
sorcières
il était cent pour cent sûr qu'il y
avait des sorcières et tous que la
question des preuves il la traitait un
peu la légère s'il voyait un chat noir
la loi ongles d'une rue il disait que
c'était la preuve qu'il ya des sorcières
mais donc des illuminés donc des gens
finalement qui parlait du diable en
parlant de saddam hussein qui comme les
islamistes parle du grand satan en
parlant les américains à une certaine
façon non saddam hussein s'était
comporté d'une manière qui correspondent
à cette description
mais malgré tout je crois que ce qui est
important c'est que de tout temps dans
la société il faut exercer le sens
critique et si l'on perd l'exercice du
sens critique on perd la science on perd
un bon ordre social aussi il ne faut
jamais croire dans les sorcières la
superstition est mauvaise et les
inspecteurs il essaye d'établir des
faits c'est leur mission et moi aussi
à l'automne 2002 je croyais qu'il y
avait des armes de destruction massive
mais les résultats de nos inspections
les faits ont montré que ce n'était pas
le cas
j'avais des doutes et en mars les
preuves étaient très faibles et en mai
nous étions pratiquement à persuader
qu'il n'y en avait pas alors en revanche
blix le président chirac vous a séduit
par sa sagesse quand vous l'avez vu vous
a dit y a pas de preuves sérieuses il a
dit la guerre et la série séduit n'est
pas persuadé persuadé non mais c'est
vrai il vous dit il nous voulons
acquérir il vous dit a pas de toit via
pas de quoi sérieuse la guerre est la
pire de toutes les solutions en
intervenant là bas les américains vont
ouvrir la boîte de pandore dont
finalement vous allez trouver chez
jacques chirac quelqu'un de très sage je
crois qu'il était réaliste
tout d'abord il était convaincu qu'il
n'y avait pas d'armes
en second lieu il estimait que les
agences de renseignement et est ce qu'il
a appelé des agences qui s'intoxiquent
l'une l'autre et il était très préoccupé
également par l'évolution de la
situation au proche orient si l'on
devait entrer en guerre et il avait
raison
est-ce que vous avez parlé de chirac
avec bush et blair
non non j'ai vu monsieur douche avant de
voir monsieur chirac je l' ai vu en
octobre 2002
monsieur chirac en janvier 2003 ne
croyait pas à hans blix que washington
avait décidé en fait la guerre depuis
longtemps depuis août 2002 et que les
inspections que vous dirigiez était
uniquement destiné à donner à l'armée
américaine le temps de se préparer au
combat
lorsque l'on parle de la décision prise
par les américains il faut penser au
président il s'agit bien du président
ils étaient nombreux au ministère de la
défense américain où l'on pensait que en
fait il n'y avait pas vraiment de cette
chaîne était du même avis à la vie
d'ailleurs mais c'est le président qui
prend la décision et je crois qu'en 2002
n'avait pas encore pris cette décision
ce n'est qu'en septembre je crois qu'il
a décidé qu'on adopterait une approche
multilatérale avec les nations unies
peut être que c'était la limite
extérieure ultime et il pensait aller on
pas les laisser faire et on verra si ça
marche mais je ne pense pas que la
décision il de tuer la prendre avant
plus tard
quel a été le comportement des irakiens
durant les inspections est-ce qu'ils
avaient vraiment envie de nous tout
montrer il y avait une grande différence
entre le comportement des irakiens à
notre encontre et à l'encontre des
autres inspecteurs d instruction d'avant
parce que il était très ouvert c'est à
dire qu'ils ou près tous les sites y
compris les palais de saddam hussein qui
s'est ouvert il ne serait pas comme moi
sur le fond il que des douze nuits en
page de documents de déclaration qu'il
nous fournissait pas beaucoup
d'informations est-ce qu'ils ont caché
des armes en syrie s'ils en avaient
caché en syrie on en aurait eu des
preuves
les l'armée américaine estime que ce
n'est pas le cas et les syriens je pense
n'aurait pas beaucoup aimé en avoir
pendant la recherche des armes de
destruction massive
avant la guerre vous avez été victime de
pressions notamment dick cheney qui vous
fait comprendre que si vos inspecteurs
ne trouve pas rapidement des armes de
destruction massive et vous pourriez
discréditer quand même il n'a pas dit
rapidement qu'il le dise qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à jeter le discrédit
sur les inspecteurs en faveur du
désarmement a semblé comprendre que cela
voulait dire que le désarmement c'était
quelque chose d'important pour lui
c'était un inspecteur pouvait-il faire
revenir tant mieux sinon ce serait eux
mêmes qu'ils le feraient alors quelques
mois plus tard toujours pas d'armes de
destruction massive bush et blair pour
convaincre leurs opinions publiques
disent avoir des preuves flagrantes et
vous vous surprenez à vous interroger
sur ses preuves
lorsqu'elles sont produites par coline
powell notamment des bandes magnétiques
qu'il fait entendre et au moment où vous
les écoutez vous vous dites mais du ca
sort l'objectif de la présentation des
preuves pas que les travaux elle était
de convaincre l'opinion publique
américaine de la présence d'armes de
destruction massive moi j'ai
effectivement assisté à cet exposé
j'avais un peu l'impression d'être au
tribunal avec un procureur qui présente
ses preuves et lorsque le procureur le
ferait il faut qu'il y est un contre
interrogatoire
je suis allé voir mes experts et je leur
ai posé la question aux pensées et les
commentaires étaient plutôt critiquée
par conséquent j'ai décidé que c'était à
moi d'aller au conseil de sécurité pour
leur dire que nous ne nous étions pas
impressionner par ses preuves
oui alors ses preuves flagrantes on a
n'a plus jamais entendu parler depuis de
toute façon non de nombreux exemples
d'autres creusent
tél
on c'est à dire qu'il ya des sites avec
des armes chimiques on avait vu des
camions de décontamination or nos
inspecteurs s'étaient rendus sur ce site
il avait pris des échantillons sur place
et il n'avait vu aucun signe de présence
d'armes biologiques chimiques et les
camions ou qu'on y avait vu des camions
de transport d'eau donc c'était vraiment
une grosse intox ou alors à ce moment-là
la campagne contre vous ce excellèrent
on vous conseille d'aller chez
l'opticien pour voir les preuves
flagrantes
vous êtes cloué au pilori présenté comme
un imbécile et comme un caniche français
c'était dur pour vous à ce moment là non
comme dit tu crois que tu es un chien de
garde mais en fait tu n'es jamais qu'un
petit caniche je trouvais ça plutôt
drôle
je n'ai pas apprécié le conseil de
sécurité c'était mon patron et le
conseil de sécurité à respecter les
inspecte aucun problème
rien de méchant alors pourtant même qu
une poubelle à l'époque aller batailler
pour avoir des preuves plus convaincante
et laisser ya n'avait pas été en mesure
de les lui donner
yasad inc je crois que c'est dans les
journaux qu'il avait rejeté toute une
série d'affaires et lui avait présenté
c'est qu'il avait gardé ce qu'il
considérait comme étant les meilleurs
renseignements mais il ya quelques jours
à peine il a dit c'est effectivement
pour un de ses cadres camions seront
transportés censé transporter des armes
biologiques que c'était une erreur et il
a dit qu'il n'aurait pas présenté ses
cages il avait su et je trouve que c'est
honnête de le dire maintenant qui a
fabriqué ces fossés la cia et le fbi
les agences de renseignement avait
confiance de nombreux transfuges
peut-être un peu trop un transfuge
tirage que ça ne les intéressait pas
beaucoup qu'il y à des inspecteurs ce
qu'ils voulaient c'est qu'on libère le
pays et le ski sont parvenus
hans blix est ce que vous pouvez dire ce
soir que les états unis ont envahi
l'irak enfants dans leurs interventions
sur des faux ils ont envahi l'irak où se
fondent sur l'argument vertu duquel il y
avait des armes de destruction massive
et un danger immédiat
l'avenant or il aurait dû savoir que les
preuves étaient trop faire plus tard on
s'est aperçu qu'il n'y avait pas d'armes
de destruction massive
s'il avait dit qu'il envahit reliera
quoi pour se débarrasser d'un affreux
dictateur et d'un régime sanguinaire
aurait été prêt mais il n'aurait pas pu
persuader le congrès américain est clair
n'aurait pas pu persuader le parlement
britannique
talleyrand guerre pour mettre fin à
cette dictature
peut-être qu'à l'avenir et dans l'avenir
des nations unies et des états unis ne
sont prêts à mettre fin aux dictatures
simplement parce que les sanguinaires et
affreuse mais haas pour l'instant non
peut-être que le jour viendra et en tout
cas c'est le souhait que je forme orale
et alors
un an après cette guerre c'est le
bourbier irakien
est-ce que vous pensez que les états
unis sont partis dans une aventure
comparable à celle du vietnam
hans blix il ya de grandes différences
entre les deux certes ils sont dans un
bourbier comme vous le dit très
justement lui mais pour l'instant il est
très difficile de savoir dans quel sens
les choses évolueront les au vietnam
il a essayé d'apporter leur appui à un
gouvernement qui ne bénéficiait pas de
l'appui du peuple
or ici les états unis essaient d'établir
un régime qui aurait et bénéficierait de
l'appui de la population ça me paraît
très difficile et c'est vrai qu'ils sont
dans une situation dont je ne dirais pas
que c'est le chaos
mais c'est certainement une situation
très difficile
vous pouvez qu'ils vont envoyer des
renforts là bas on parle de 500 mille
hommes sur place vous pensez qu'ils vont
le faire
mais plus que maintenant est ce que vous
croyez que le transfert de souveraineté
pourrait se faire comme prévu au 30 juin
2004 les dirigeants politiques
américains aussi en doute mais il faut
se poser la question qu'est ce qu'un
transfert de souveraineté s'il ya encore
l'armée américaine sur place qui
maîtrise le pays
est ce que vous croyez que cette
histoire peut coûter la présidence à
george bush
le cas sera en tout cas une influence un
taux record vous était que ça lui coûte
la présidence tous les politiques
doivent payer lorsqu'ils sont des choses
qui ne sont pas tout à fait sincère je
crois qu'ils ont vraiment manipuler un
jeu la formation c'est vraiment l'art de
la persuasion élections libres et c'est
une vision un petit peu biaisé un angle
donc ça n'est pas du mensonge mais ça
n'est pas tout à fait la vérité dans ces
quais qu'il est bien pour le monde que
bush s'en aille
vous personnellement d'avoir une
politique étrangère qui serait nettement
plus mainstream amer
bush mais frisait les questions unis et
il préférait y aller seul plutôt que de
demander à leurs alliés de les aider
mais il ne pouvait pas en fait le faire
seul par le passé les états unis ont été
un bon leader ils ont essayé de créer de
renforcer la communauté internationale
d'organiser les nations unies qui est
loin d'être une organisation parfaite
qui a beaucoup de faiblesses mais c'est
la seule que nous avons donc il faut la
réparer et non pas l'ignorer justement
est ce que voudrait que les nations
unies peuvent faire encore quelque chose
pour l'irak
oui parce que les nations unies sont un
symbole de légitimité et les irakiens ne
veulent pas être sous la tutelle d'un
pouvoir d'occupation pour les allemands
quand le japon ça va fonctionner mais
pas pour l'irak
ils se sentent humiliés et je crois que
les nations unies pourraient les aider à
ne plus se sentir humilié
pour l'instant je ne sais pas très bien
comment mais peut-être j'espère en tout
cas que ce sera le cas merci hans blix
irak s'est invité chez fayard juste une
dernière question en zik ce les armes de
destruction massive vous avez cherché
sur le lit non
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant en dissociant
c
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi si albert dupontel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors bon soir ont bien vu l'interview
de hans blix là c'est étonnant quand
même
guy oui bah oui avait pas de preuve les
mecs nous a complètement manipulé
ça s'appelle se [ __ ] de la gueule du
monde voilà entier voilà georges
marchais talents culinaires des mots et
voilà antisociale de l'état
un message de georges pour dire toi même
alors albert dupontel acteurs haute
réalisateur aujourd'hui c'est l'acteur
que nous recevons pour un film de
nicolas boukhrief qui s'appelle le
convoyeur avec jean dujardin françois
berléand vous sorti le 14 avril
c'est le troisième film de nicolas
boukhrief et le film se passe dans une
société de convoyage de fonds
c'est la première fois et c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs ni les français ni les
américains ni personne n'avait pensé à
ça avant alors c'est marrant c'est qu'on
voyait ans et des ouvriers en fait on y
gagne abbaoui enfin c'est bizarre c'est
des mecs qui gagnent un salaire de
misère pour transporter des millions
mais ça fait pas risquer leur vie
oui ça fait partie des aberrations de la
société voilà actuelle la même façon
qu'il ya un président des etats-unis qui
dit que les armes n'existe pas il ya on
donne 1000 euros par mois des ti pour
transporter des millions d'euros dans
des fourgons c'est un peu un peu
aberrant app-ps au critt un peu faux cul
un peu anti sociale comme vous dites oui
antisociales c'est très bien documenté
une enquête qui a été fait par par une
journaliste avant et tout est vrai dans
ce film pas tout tout tout mais n'ont
pas démenti la globalité
voilà c'est un film qui était un
suspense sur un fond sociétal
on pourrait dire je voulais parler que
dans les villages
là-bas les émissions culturelles
associées table très bien c'est un film
noir un film de genre qui rend compte la
vie d'un groupe emblématique de la
société actuelle voilà c'est de penser
le mec paumé qui sont armés avec une
tentation permanente évidemment depuis
qu'elle fric qu'ils transportent
ouais ouais c'est un petit peu ça quand
même un paradoxe effectivement alors au
début votre personnage alexandre se fait
engager par cette petite société de
transport de fonds
les affaires vont pas bien on parle de
vente de bilan
dépôt de bilan vente aux américains donc
un certain stress d'entreprise
effectivement qui doublées d'un stress
et dès qu'ils sortent du fourgon ils
peuvent faire de leur vie et au travail
peuvent perdre leur boulot ça fait
beaucoup quand même
alors en plus cette petite société est
victime de deux braquages répétés alors
on se demande s'il ya pas une complicité
entre les convoyeurs et les truands qui
l'est qui les attaquent et on se demande
qui vous êtes au départ on vous voit
arriver alors on this impôts mais qui a
trouvé un boulot il fait ça parce qu'il
sait pas quoi faire d'autre
ensuite on pense que vous êtes un flic
peut-être qui est en train de l'infiltré
la société pour savoir qui organise ces
braquages
on pense de petit volume d'air un
braqueur évidemment je vais pas vous
dire
espérant conjoncture c'est une des
forces du film c'est vrai qu'à 45
minutes on sait pas ce qui se passe ni
ce qu'il vient faire
ouais et pourtant présent son fauteuil
[Musique]
et vous 45 minutes quand le mobile
apparaît du monsieur je le trouve très
touchant très émouvant est là fort voilà
est-ce que vous pourriez dire en
regardant votre caméra magnéto serge
magnéto serge savard le texte est pas
compliqué
on est mariés les enfants l'appellent
werder
des antécédents psychiatriques mon
territoire où c'est tant d'armes
respectent la moi c'est jacky les
nouveaux appartements mais c'est la
momie
tiens c'est pas compliqué on sort on va
dans des charges petit bois saint loup
avant je travaillais dans une banque n'a
fait de changer dis moi tu t'es déjà
fait braquer mois
c'est un jeu du chargement imagine juste
un sac
histoire de sortir moins con pour les
trois attaquants n ya qu une neuf gains
il a cependant demandé moi je dis que
c'est les même si oui les points chauds
et des itinéraires qui sont plus
dangereux de tous qu'est ce que vous
faites là le journaliste écrivain
j'avais demandé à ce que j'aime les
personnes dans ma chambre jamais
tu es là pour l'adrénaline pas pour
[Musique]
voilà le convoyeur le mythe de la
boukhrief avec albert dupontel est notre
invité ce soir
alors le personnage c'est un personnage
comme ça très costaud très musclé on
voit faire de la gym et tout en même
temps d'une grande fragilité
on a toujours l'impression qui va partir
quoi l'idée nicolas maîtresse est assez
joli c'est habile scénaristiquement et
au niveau du cinéma c'est de dire on va
montrer la force plutôt de l'avoir la
jouer comme ça on va garder le jeu pour
l'émotion la maladresse le pathétique le
ridicule d'un grotesque le bateau est ce
que tout ce personnage véhicule un peu
comme le docteur saxe dans un autre
registre un peu comme dampierre
d'irréversible voilà c'est des registres
que j'aime bien ouais alors on souffre
quand il fait de la muscu mais on
souffre encore plus quand on croise son
regard est quelque chose qui se dégage
de lui qui est assez pathétique
d'ailleurs puisque quand on vous voilà
vous avez l'aï allumé malicieux les dans
le film vous êtes vraiment des cons paye
tout est possible et bien payé il ya du
jardin aussi jean dujardin qui est
excellent je ne sais pas du tout j'ai
pas la télé d'ailleurs je n'ai pas la
télé
non c'est pour ça que je viens jamais
venu si j'avais dû mission avant non
mais là jean dujardin je connaissais pas
et qui est très sympathique berlin
exceptionnel va me connaissait par
ailleurs claude perron que je
connaissais sans avoir la télévision et
nicolas marié qui joue également dans le
bon dernier dans le créateur et une
flopée d'autres acteurs roman formidable
pas une grande réussite de boukhrief que
je salue le personnage est éminemment
doux et sympathique intègre authentique
voilà très bien on l'applaudît
ça sort le 14 avril alors j'ai mis
antisocial tout à l'heure parce que
c'est pas mal c'est antisocial vous en
vous en convenez non vous avez été
renvoyée d'école maternelle à quatre ans
et demi c'est quand même pas mal non
archives
c'est assez vrai le pire c'est vrai et
ensuite vous étiez à l'école paul bert à
conflans et on était obligé de vous
mettre du chatterton sur la bouche pour
vous clouer le bec suis effaré par vous
renseigne vrai mais bon des cordes quand
même temps et toujours c'est le secteur
5 ans et un fumier d'instituteurs
certainement pédophiles mais à l'époque
c'était motorisés qu'aujourd'hui qui m'a
foutu du chatterton sur la bouche
rencontre j'avais voulu brûler sa maison
non il ya cinq ans quand même j'étais
petit j'étais si vous voulez sa femme
j'avais repéré que ce fumier je savais
où il habitait et acheter des glaces est
clairement quelle adresse
gso portable j'ai tout et je me rappelle
qu'il avait une coccinelle plusieurs
fois j'aurais bien vu cette coccinelle
partir en fumée
voilà sans façon world is nothing
sociale la seule chose qui arrive à vous
calmer un peu c'est la gym
ouaip il ya pas que ça ait des parents
gentil surtout qu'ils m'ont un peu calmé
un peu dirigé la drogue la drogue assez
tôt et voilà une relation incestueuse
depuis novembre faisait beaucoup de
sport intime huawei j'étais assez assez
agitée de l'essence ce qui vous calme
est plutôt c'était le cinéma vous
passiez votre vie enfermée dans les
salles ça je fuyais la réalité comme
vous vous chargez pas quand vous l'avez
fait du vous n'avez fut la réalité
certainement aussi puisque aussi la main
vision vous continuez au cinéma - c'est
encore pire
voilà il y avait ainsi les mots bout de
la rue s'appelle palace voilà alors
j'allais vraiment papa qui était docteur
dans la même rue je disais j'ai eu de
l'argent pour acheter les fournitures
scolaires ça se terminer par un billet à
10 15 ou 20 francs à vous rentriez à
deux heures de l'après midi une sortie à
minuit il faut un peu de temps enfin
jeunes gens rentrent à plus tôt et puis
un peu plus vieux je rentre je rentre et
et tous est d'eric rohmer achats sont
d'ailleurs j'avais c'était la synergie
pas de la cinéphilie
alors ensuite vous suivez l'orientation
paternelle pour devenir médecin fait
qu'à 35 de médecine jusqu'au jour où aux
urgences albert dupontel vous voyez
débarquer à un mec de 20 balais
complètement bousillé par un accident de
moto et là vous vous dites il faut vivre
quoi il faut faire ce qu'on a envie de
faire dans la vie parce que finalement
ça tire a rien fait j'ai été un peu
aidés
mis à pied pour un stage tout le monde
était soulager les malades comme les
médecins que je m'en aille
c'est vrai j'avais été très frappé par
six mois du rejoint exactement à
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy franchement
la nuit vous imaginez pas ce qui se
passe
j'ai été très frappée je me dis si vivre
savoir des émotions autant se dépêcher
besoin parce que c'est assez aléatoire
là vous vous inscrivez un cours de
théâtre et puis après on connaît la
suite il ya eu d'abord le one man show
qui était extraordinaire c'est à dire il
fait des sketches comme le bac français
comme rambo et c'est un truc que j'ai
pas compris vous a vu un tel succès
quand vous avez commencé à faire des
sketchs bien je vous ai dit non ce que
je fais c'est du cinéma et je vais
toujours faire du cinéma mais le
spectacle a été la poterne qui m'a
permis de rentrer dans la forteresse du
showbiz c'est une sorte de cri primal
mais je trouvais ça pauvre et frustrant
fin que je voulais faire du cinoche
bernie la bande dessinée du spectacle
créateur laborieusement attaque le
prochain enfermés dehors sera toujours
spectacle voilà il ya une bernie
évidemment le créateur ensuite l'acteur
avec des films aussi important que la
maladie de saxe de ville alors vous êtes
très lonesome cowboy un vous vous êtes
très anti société du spectacle dizaine
de comptes à rendre à personne je vis
comme gandhi
je n'ai besoin de rien on ne peut pas
m'avoir le vrai luxe dans ce métier
c'est la liberté de dire non ou de dire
oui je suis aussi franc que bush
ouais non c'est vrai vous je suis un peu
discret voilà bon ça suffit d'être
marginalisés pourquoi pas mais je suis
un peu discret c'est tout je suis pas je
suis pas hystérique avec les médias
j'avais failli être un peu les gens à la
télé ça la culture de l'ennui la télé
comme ça vous êtes une agressivité jeu
précis mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas
la télé depuis dix ans je m'en passe
très bien et heureusement je les ai pas
je mets beaucoup de films j'ai 800 dvd
milka sept jeux libres etc
et voilà et la télé qu'on arrache à
l'automne gère l affaire j'ai regardé
c'est fou le chose de choses inutiles à
part votre émission mais des choses
inutiles qu'on peut voir non mais je
mangeais tradition survient mais là je
pense que cette émission est utile non
mais souvent ya un procès par exemple
enfin se relâche pas mais on nous a fait
un gros procès et sur bernie sur la
violence au cinéma et sur irréversible
gens parlent pas à ce film là d'ailleurs
pas taillé moins de 12 ans
baptisé donc il pas si lens a toutefois
je mets donc j'ai pas la télé mais la
violence au cinéma c'est un faux procès
est ce que le cinéma est un lieu protégé
c'est un lieu de polémique d'expression
de débats bc protéger on rentre dans une
salle de cinéma au hasard le même
quotidien barrière est fascinant famille
c'est franchement il s'est gouré c'est
un consommateur crétins tant pis pour
lui
pargo la télévision rend dans la chambre
d'hôtel craque on appuie sur le bouton
je tombais celle sur elle si la semaine
dernière les mecs qui brûle dans la jeep
les américains dépassé par la foule
j'étais très choquée parce que j'étais
paperasse ah ouais donc une perversité
eux se cache derrière l'alibi de la
formation entre alibi d'information et
voyeurisme il ya un truc une frontière
qui franchit allègrement donc le procès
de la violence au cinéma
montcuq quoi ça n'existe pas assez c'est
le jeu mais qui va au cinéma voir un
film qui sait ce qui va voir sauf si
c'est un combat soeur s'est testé la tv
comme ça non mais je n'aime pas ce
qu'elle me fais pas mon temps voilà sauf
quand je suis là bien sûr c'est pas une
attitude un peu snob ça non écoutez
franchement d'abord elle est
involontaire c'est un jour un jour m'a
coupé cas parce que je payais pas donc
au départ je vais les voir et puis je me
suis rendu compte que je pensais que je
mens pas ça très bien
donc non mais c'est pas un peu snob ne
pas payer le câble c'est ce que je vais
vous faire maintenant
non non non elle à prendre un pain mais
l'interview un parmi d'autres
[Musique]
j'examine pardon j'avais déjà vu cette
émission une fois d'ailleurs j'ai été
très choquée c'est j'avais presque envie
de venir en courant c'était quand il y
avait un philosophe parisien type
closerie des lilas qui s'appelait
finkielkrault oui c'est ça c'est un nom
qui ressemble un carillon qui expliquait
en gros que les palestiniens est il
cette étape désespérée mais qu'ils
avaient le désespoir pas très poli
puisqu'il allait se faire sauter chez
les gens j'ai trouvé ça totalement
indécent l'éviter tellement grossier et
malvoyants qu'il a réussi à faire
pleurer les délicieuses du de binoche
moi je me suis profondément choquée j'ai
presque en visite en bretagne de prendre
la voiture et d'intervenir sur le
plateau et dire voilà parce que quand on
en arrive à se faire sauter avec des
cartouches de dynamite c'est qu'on est
franchement désespéré voilà il n'y a pas
de politesse ou pas avoir des espoirs
donc cette émission
heureusement que t'as pas la télé sites
en bretagne ces prêts à prendre la
bagnole faire 500 banques pour être un
bon pull un mec qu'a dit une connerie
ouais imaginons je serai pas trop encore
mais alors un parmi d'autres donc si
vous étiez un des sept péchés capitaux
vous seriez lequel la luxure je ferai
plus souvent la télévision
parce que si vous étiez un des dix
commandements tu ne tueras point comme
ça je n'hésiterai pas un des sept nains
simple est comme ça je pourrais me
présenter à la campagne présidentielle
américaine branché en toi aussi
si vous étiez un dessin elle maintient
le dernier le cinquième pour être le
chouchou est une des sept merveilles du
monde
les jardins suspendus de babylone qui
aujourd'hui se trouve à bagdad comme ça
je ferai du jardinage avec interdiction
pour les chars de marché sur la pelouse
ça bravo
si vous étiez un des cinq sens l'odorat
pour m'autodétruire lors de la promotion
de mes films je vous étiez 1,17 à le
cinéma pour apprendre quelques trucs un
des quatre points cardinaux du sud pour
pouvoir perdre le nord en permanence en
bravo si vous étiez à les trois
mousquetaires d'artagnan pour piquer les
ferrer la reine plutôt que de lui rendre
sa couronne
voilà est un des sept mercenaires du
brenner pour avoir une coupe de cheveux
toujours à la mode ça vous étiez albert
dupontel un des douze travaux d'hercule
les écuries d'augias en faisant passer
le fleuve par matignon l'elysée
l'assemblée nationale la 7e 31 jours du
mois le premier pendant les vacances et
dernier pendant que je travaille si vous
étiez à 17 jours de la semaine le lundi
parce que tout est encore possible et un
des cinq continents l'afrique pour me
venger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant chez
cette base
s
6 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quand vous n'avez pas la télé vous
ne savez pas clos dit du coup comme il
n'a pas la tête
séverine ferrer qui présente le 20
heures sur france 3 depuis une semaine
topless nouvelle rocade estonie très
bien quand tu très heureuse en tout cas
c'est mon but dans la vie
si tu as la série j'ai toujours trouvé
intrigant donc s'attendre à passer d'un
très grave
le patin très peu de temps mais je fais
bien passé donc tu rigoles inconvenant
attention alors séverine ferrer donc
fan2 comme ça vous regarde aurait
maintenant sur m6 le samedi à 11h45
mais en plus les fringues puisque vous
avez une ligne de vêtements séverine
enceinte pour la femme enceinte lorsque
vous et c'est pas du séverine ferrer
voilà ça s'appelle miss maman vous êtes
obligés de faire des enfants pour
promouvoir votre votre ligne ou non la
preuve que non vu que j'avais une
obligation
et voilà je les réalise et nous publier
un livre qui s'appelle des étoiles plein
la tête chez robert laffont c'est votre
autobiographie mais je voudrais conseil
albert est un disque un album qui sort
le 27 avril
en attendant il ya un single qui
s'appelle dieu me pardonne et un parfum
non ça c'était il ya quelques jours
[Musique]
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
il n'y a pas eu des films en crypté
avant non non non non je croyais ne l'a
pas fait de film en courtes et n'importe
quoi sans qu'il est très accroché la
manette et titubant tel schéma de
magnéto serge ses biens avec de fidèles
non c'est vrai regard de toute urgence
comptez un peu à peu changé internet ici
il a dit magnéto serge serge magnéto
serge dominique fénéon chu où est ce
qu'on dit ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]
dieu me pardonne ses rimes
ce que de l'album qui s'appelle séverine
terreur sortie le 27 avril
tu veux t'en avais toi oui il n'a pas
aimé le projet est scandalisé par
l'obligation ça m'a un peu mustier ce
qui pousse de toute façon il n'y a
aucune chance à ben voilà battu résine
et je n'ai je parle de ma campagne
j'avais regardé son merci infiniment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime ce genre de mec ou ça te fait
peur toi je suis intrigué je demande
qu'à connaître
ouais tu demande qu'à connaître à lui
n'ont visiblement un bain visiblement
non mais je crois que personne sérieuse
sans fax moi il m'a dit je respecte la
[ __ ] je te retrouver sa part un
problème
non mais c'est pas c'est pas votre votre
type de mec vous le trouvez un peu trop
fou j'aime bien les hommes plus âgés que
moi c'est déjà pour nous est déjà pas
mal
donc en fait c'est pas mon style de m
mais je demande qu'à connaître comment
ça va avec fred est là tout va très bien
bien alors vendez un livre qui s'appelle
des étoiles plein la tête
publié chez robert laffont alors voilà
vous raconter votre vie la réunion avec
vos parents blanche et eric blanche
employés dans un salon de coiffure
eric qui fait des petits boulots on n'a
jamais très bien su ce qui faisait votre
père quand même ça fait il était
représentant il a été coiffeur moment et
représentant un coiffeur ça veut dire
qu'elle est bisexuelle ou pas du tout
tout comme on n'a pas parlé mais je ne
crois pas c'était vraiment une très
belle éducation je suis très contente
j'avais pape à la maison et maman qui
travaille m -e
c'était vraiment une enfance très
équilibré pourquoi pas dans le sens
inverse tout va bien alors blanche votre
mère tombe enceinte et là ils partent à
montpellier où vous naissez heureusement
et là c'est le drame
non c'est non justement c'est très
touchant oui c'est très difficile bien
sûr mais alors il ya une scène très
touchante c'est parce que ses parents
mais pas beaucoup d'argent et son père
le soir ils enlevaient les affaires de
la valise et il faisait un petit lit
dans la valise pour séverine c'est joli
c'est mignon comme tout valise 84
voilà donc il retourne la réunion est là
dès l'âge de 4 ans vous vous rendez
compte que vous avez envie de faire du
spectacle tu très attiré par ce métier
moi je suis à treize mille kilomètres
une petite réunionnaise qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec ce métier je
regarde la télévision et ça me fascine
et je sais au fond de moi que je suis je
suis fait pour ça mais pour moi ça me
paraît être tellement un accessible qu'à
aucun moment ça me met fleurs l'esprit
que c'est vraiment fait des petites
chorégraphies
oui je commence sur gotainer
taxant bon voilà ça a été la première et
c'est celle qui m'a donné envie de faire
des chorégraphies ensuite donc j'étais
les mini miss réunion à l'âge de 7 ans
et puis vous devenez un petit peu la
mascotte de lille non vous faites des
publicités pour la promotion de la
réunion 20 grâce à alexandre mini miss
réunion
basique où tout a été lancée un peu
malgré moi donc j'ai appris j'ai appris
sur le tas et c'est vrai que mes parents
étaient pas du tout dans le métier donc
j'ai vraiment appris sur le terrain
assez votre père qui s'occupe de tout il
ya des rumeurs qui commença à courir sur
lui ont dit qu il vous prend un peu
votre argent tout cela s'est vraiment
fait en tout cas mon père ne m'a jamais
réclamé un centime et il n'a jamais
voulu que j'aide mes parents dans des
situations plus ou moins critique donc
nantes où tout était vraiment en
harmonie en osmose tous ensemble ait
jamais eu ce genre de problème
alors vous raconter une scène très
difficile un traumatisme consécutif à la
révélation de la non existence du père
noël
aïe ben oui ça paraît futile et c'est
important mais ça peut détruire les vies
entières et les gens qui tombent dans la
dope à cause de ça mais c'est possible
moi quand on me dit que les oeufs de
pâques c'était une connerie bain
j'essaie de l'accusatrice énervé qui
vous occupent les choses mais le passage
du père noël t'as pas peur qui est trop
de gamins qui laissent des plumes en
lisant des passages à un peur pour
l'appât du livre parce que je finis par
ainsi jésus mais j'étais bouleversé je
me suis empressé de l'oublier tout de
suite après
je voulais pas traîner père noël existe
toujours mais là à tu vois alors oui
bien là en fait vos débuts d'animatrice
à l'âge de 10 ans et puis là c'est la
rencontre avec un dénommé luc russell
alors lui c'est vraiment la caricature
du producteur vous faites un petit
groupe qui s'appelle baby show vous êtes
invités à paris par patrick sabatier et
lui alors il prend ses ex trop bien les
mecs qui font ça la production donne de
l'argent pour vous habitiez au concorde
lafayette
ils vivent dans un hôtel à châtillon
malakoff garde à différents égards la
différence mais je la prends bien plus
tard je l'apprends par hasard je reviens
à paris je m'installe et un jour
l'assistante patrick savatier me laisse
en fait j'étais sûr passage clouté il
laisse le passage et je le reconnais et
tous étaient bien au concorde lafayette
je fais de quoi tu parles alors non pas
du tout on était à châtillon malakoff
donc sans arrêt mais en même temps
aujourd'hui ce sont des souvenirs qui
restent il dut y avait ça prend aux
tripes quand même toutes ces histoires
c'est intéressant
non mais je trouve ça un peu violent
pour les gens qui vont toi c'est quand
même fort ce que tu racontes c'est pas
rien c'est pas des conneries c'est pas
anodin c'est pas anodin c'est des
municipal bonds marqué plusieurs
générations
cette carte de presse par les gens
prendre des précautions oratoires avant
de dire ce livre et les passages qui
peuvent heurter la sensibilité mais
certains qui sont très émouvant quand tu
as fait la queue à auch en 20 minutes
alors pourquoi votre claire signe avec
ce producteur luc russell alors que
c'est de toute évidence à votre père
anglais proposent tous ces bien que peu
de temps avant un producteur nous
propose de devenir de faire un single et
en l'occurrence il nous propose pas de
nous héberger de quelque part nous
accueillir et ce luth nous propose tout
ça donc évidemment mon père et
aujourd'hui je comprends très bien
puisque je suis une maman au journal
donc je comprends vraiment ce qu'il a
voulu faire essayer de partir vers la
sécurité et protéger sa petite famille
malheureusement ça n'a pas été c'est
quand vous arrivez à paris une usa temps
soit disant il est pas là est obligé
d'aller habiter dans un grenier ouais
c'est un truc tu veux qu'on sent le
passage des greniers ah non tu veux tout
seul faire chialer hélas ils auront le
passage du col est occupée autres c'est
la salle de bain pour le coup le petit
oui hélas hélas il est obligé quand même
de le menacer
pour qu'il vous près de 117 mètres
carrés à boulogne le luxe c'est surtout
que la rentrée scolaire va démarrer
qu'on est toujours pas inscrit à l'école
et que c'est un peu dangereux
j'imagine la galère la manne on rigole
on rigole et j'imagine large mais
franchement pourquoi je mets à votre
place avec vos parents avec les la grand
mère elle suivait toujours là
heureusement je dirais elle restait bien
des choses dans tous les cas je serai
beaucoup de mal à vous en débarrasser de
ce producteur c'est moi le mec qui
imagine ici mais sur cette famille c'est
terrible à rien apprendre quoi
heureusement je suis là je pense qu'on
n'aurait pas franchi ouais je vais car
beaucoup de mal à vous en débarrasser
votre père est obligé de le menacer de
le balancer au mari de sa maîtresse mais
ça a très bien marché
il lui a dit si tu es si tu continues
ouais j'ai dû continuer je vais dire on
arrive à venir de sa famille enjeux
communs donc forcément ce moment là on
va vite vers l'extrême et on trouve
toutes les solutions pour et ça a très
bien marché puisqu'il a pris peur et il
a déchiré qu'on fera dans tous les cas
ça vous a pas empêché de faire carrière
mais c'est vrai que c'était une époque
peuvent être facilement et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que bon
c'est vrai qu'on le connaît en tant
qu'animatrice sur m6 mais on sait pas
par où je suis passé
et quelque part j'ai envie d'expliquer
que c'est pas si facile que ça
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
très facile de réussir mais c'est
beaucoup de travail et c'est du talent
beaucoup de rigueur et je suis fière et
des belles anecdotes des belles
anecdotes mais qui forge un caractère
caractère bien trempé est ce que malgré
le fait qu'elle accepte même de
continuer à vivre alors que le père noël
n'existe pas de moi je dis chapeau bas
quel courage
l'inexistence du du père noël vous a pas
empêché de rencontrer le dalaï lama
heureusement quand même le grand moment
de votre vie séverine non c'était un
canular car il n'existe pas
aussi j'ai des goûts de la zone quand
c'est vrai qu'en séverine voit le dalaï
lama elle dit de grosses larmes
jaillissent et ruisselle le long de
mijoux et quand le dallai lama voix
séverine suivante plus un très beau
sourire ce qui s'est passé entre eux
tous ces manques tu arrives pas conquis
lis pas la presse pipole moi qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en italie s'est passé il
sera grèce non non on disait à séverine
alain démarra moment et beaucoup
d'histoires dans les journaux dans voici
tous à des liaisons qui n'existaient pas
enfin des trucs et un jour elle dit je
vais en parler au dalaï lama
mais comment on fait les portables je
résume ça s'est pas passé comme ça il se
trouvait c'était une période noire dans
ma vie j'ai décidé de tout balancer de
partir pendant 1 mois et je suis parti
je suis très heureuse est parti mais
quand vous voyez vous dalaï lama bolide
de grosses larmes jaillissaient
ruisselle le long de mes jouets selon le
dalaï lama s'écrie c'est drôle je fais
cet effet là à toutes les femmes mais on
est super sympa
figure toi il éclate de rire tous les
deux avec le dalaï lama et rôle dans
l'air sans oublier bien sûr jamais pour
amélie est fabuleux et je le souhaite à
tout le monde
est-ce que c'est toujours le petit
mouchoir en papier que le dalaï lama
vous a donné
vous l'avez vous le gardez la maison
bien protégés tu es là incliné devant sa
table donner un kleenex m'a donné sa
santé
et toi tu vois transformé sans objet
pratique et si tu tiens c'est lamentable
tu veut désacraliser un objet magnifique
[Musique]
non
je
tous
[Musique]
dieu me pardonne on va vers une
interview dieu me pardonne
[Musique]
on va donner vie ensemble séverine
ferrer ce que vous avez à vous faire
pardonner
quel est le mensonge que dieu doit vous
pardonner d'avoir un petit peu menti en
amour de temps en temps ah bon table ici
vous avez dit à des garçons vous les
émirs c'est pas vrai souvent parfois non
je suis très sincère mais des fois on se
rend compte que c'est pas la bonne
personne mais un peu tard et on l'a déjà
dit et l'histoire d'amour que vous
aimeriez que dieu vous pardonne pas
celle qui s'est pas super bien terminé
mais bon si laquelle il y en a eu une
histoire d'amour qui a été marquante et
avec le chanteur
un chanteur y en a eu plusieurs quatre
ans avec marcel amont sérénité
c'est une histoire avec un garçon qui
vous je suis resté assez longtemps 3
open en trois ans ce n'est pas rien dieu
me pardonne
[Musique]
m
à le gros mot que vous aimeriez que dieu
vous pardonne à
j'ai tendance à dire biteng tout ça va
non je vais je suis assez sage mois et
la drogue que vous aimeriez que dieu
vous pardonne jamais jamais non jamais
j'ai jamais essayé mais c'est ça ma
drogue c'est l'amour ouais comme patrick
sébastien c'est non c'est vrai non je
n'ai pas peur d'être un peu trop
caricatural qu'en maintenant non parce
que je suis comme ça je vais pas me
mentir je vais pas jouer à la fille
qu'il l'a fait alors qu'elle n'a pas
fait je suis honnête je suis vieille un
point et le vol que vous aimeriez que
dieu vous pardonne jamais fait un tout
petit à l'âge de 4 ans non mais attendez
vous n'êtes pas ok podium là pour dire
la vérité pas vous mentir c'est vrai je
n'ai jamais volé qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez que dieu vous pardonne alors
d'avoir perdu autant de temps avec des
histoires qui n'ont mais qui met en a
plusieurs
[Musique]
un moment j'ai cru que cette chanson
c'est un hommage à moi non ah non j'ai
cru que c'est un hommage à l'émission
présent peut-être peut-être qui sait
pour elle ça peut marcher avec lui ça ne
regarde que nous ouais vous regretter un
peu belle expérience
et maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais si meego l'arrêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nicolas rey bonsoir séverine ferrer
mariée mère de famille très bien nicolas
rey célibataire prêt à tout ça va
nicolas très bien ah qu'il est beau non
oui il est vachement bien nicolas mais
magnifique n'avait pas l'air convaincu
secrète pas au premier abord comme ça
faut 20 minutes et fait leurs gammes et
un très bon et un très bon regard mais
en même temps vous êtes mariés vous avez
des enfants et c'est surtout à croire au
père noël
me collard et donc après 13 minutes
mémoire courte et un début prometteur
vous publié au diable vauvert courir à
30 ans vous êtes un petit peu le
prototype de ce qu'on peut appeler le
nouvel avenant d'une certaine façon
pourquoi je sais pas vous avez cette
fragilité du nouvel homme le nouvel
homme pleure au cinéma non par exemple à
moi ça m'est arrivé de pleurer cinéma
injecterait pour un lundi matin au pathé
wepler pour sur la route de madison
ouais parce que c'était lundi matin non
non c'était parce que j'avais pas encore
vu le film devait baffie que j'ai
toujours pas vu d'ailleurs mais je vais
le voir bien se marrer tout le monde te
parle de temps que les gens ont envie de
le voir ma télé peu au cinéma
c'est quand on était dans les salles ça
les dérangeait pas devenir un film culte
par exemple j'ai plus rien rien bambi tu
as quand même c'est quand le chasseur et
tu la maman t'a channel sales nouvelle
offre voilà madame c'est un mec qui dit
je t'aime uniquement par texto c'est
vrai nicolas bal et ouais enfin par
texto ouais c'est vrai que les textos ça
a changé pas mal de choses non mais moi
c'est des choses nous envoyer des textos
souvent c'est passer les sentiments par
les textos mais plutôt à votre mari à
vos amants comment ça se passe ça dépend
c'est un nouvel homme sa nouvelle ère
nouvelle a mis les prêts à tout donner
pour un baiser mais rien pour une vie en
couple par exemple c'est vrai dans
l'instant oui est ce que le nouvel homme
pratique le cunnilingus avant qu'on lui
propose une fellation plus qui va voir
ouais ça arrive à grave puis l'intérêt
même sens fellation un tu vas
heureusement c'est quand même un endroit
quand on fait l'amour avec quelqu'un
quand on baise avec quelqu'un c'est
quand même l'un des derniers endroits où
il n'y a pas de compétition on a un peu
la paix donc on a le droit d'embrasser
une fille entre les cuisses sans
forcément attendre comme dans le libre
échange une fellation en retour quoi je
pense donc c'est ça un nouvel homme toi
séverine si si vous avez pas fait que
vous voulez un fait ça donne envie force
est évidemment les jets ont bien reçu le
message que ça il va et veut même
séverine vous aimez donc
bien jouer c'est bien quand je gage m'en
donnez donc courir à 30 ans raconte la
vie de cinq homme de 30 ans confronté
chacun au choix de la séparation ou de
l'engagement dans le couple bref être ou
ne pas être
ce que vous appelez victime volontaire
du couple ça veut dire quoi ça victime
volontaire du couple c'est bascule quand
même aujourd'hui tout le monde a peur
donc on a peur quand on est célibataire
et puis on a peur aussi
quand on est célibataire on a peur de ne
pas trouver quelqu'un ne pas s'engager
ne pas être en couple et quand on est en
couple on a peur de ne jamais être à
nouveau célibataire
donc on a peur de tout on a peur d'avoir
un enfant on a peur de jamais en avoir
on a constamment peur donc une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple c'est
quelqu'un qui à reculons décide à un
moment donné de se mettre en couple
à défaut d'avoir réalisé un peu le
l'idéal amoureux qui l'avait quand il
avait 14 ans et qui regardait vers et on
à la boum 2 cambrai toi oui j'ai compris
et je suis assez d'accord avec lui on
peut pas dire sauf la fin il a merdé
mais c'est vrai que mon la peur les gens
ont peur de s'engager ils ont peur la
taille de quelqu'un l'a peut-être
quelqu'un tu as peur d'avoir ne pas voir
ne pas pouvoir avoir des enfants tu as
peur dans la voix cca victime volontaire
du koala bah oui c'est ça au montage ces
temps fou oui je sache pourquoi il est
intéressant de commencer parce que j'ai
pas compris alors courir à 30 ans
raconte la vie de cinq homme de 30 ans
confronté chacun au choix de la la
séparation l'investissement dans le
couple bref être ou ne pas être
vous appelez une victime volontaire du
couple c'est quoi une victime volontaire
du couple ces calculs
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
particulier
c'est quoi je vais essayer je crois que
c'est clair dire quelque chose à boire
des galets
[Musique]
c'est à dire que en fait j'ai essayé
d'expliquer les choses un peu simple
simplement en fait par exemple prenons
l'exemple de séverine séverine avec
frédéric samson mahbod frédéric avant
d'inscrire c'est compliqué d'expliquer
la lenteur du petit younes et séverine
par exemple et comme nous tous un une
victime volontaire de la vie en couple
c'est à dire qu avant d'inscrire dans le
temps une histoire dans sa vie amoureuse
séverine a eu d'autres histoires avant
non je pense avec des c'est pas des
gentils et en fait avant de t'engager
avec frédéric tu as voilà est inconnu
avant d'engager de t'engager avec
frédéric tu as eu un peu peur quoi en
fait
il a fallu que je passe par là pour me
rendre compte au sein de me rendre
compte que c'était vraiment le bon donc
non je suis le couple c'est magique
ben on lui dit que tu es une victime de
lenteurs du couple non c'est vrai qu'à
un moment on a toujours peur s'est
jamais le moment n'est jamais prêt pour
un enfant on est passé mais je t'aime
moi non plus et un moment si on n'ose
pas les choses on y viendra jamais donc
je suis très heureuse et puis je suis en
couple c'est une victime volontaire du
boucau lattre saleh la patate nico
longtemps de l'avion en couple c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui
qui a peur et qui va malgré tout et en
même temps donc il se considère comme
une victime volontaire donc cette
personne a peur d'ouvrir les verts bon
alors c'est simple une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple c'est pas
compliqué une victime volontaires de la
ville
est-ce que tu ton éditeur il est là ou
pas parce qu'il doit être lisse en
grande forme
une victime volontaire de la vie en
couple
gt c'est quelqu'un qui accepte de nos
jours et ce n'est pas évident l'amour
sans les détritus ce voilà ça c'est
cette voie là ce sera coupée au montage
qui arrivait enfin là c'est simple avant
en gros nos grands parents pour donner
des exemples un peu concrets pour éviter
que certaines personnes ne comprennent
pas avant nos grands parents quand ils
avaient du pain par exemple le lendemain
le pain duris
en fait il le transformait en levure il
est donnée aux poules ils ont fait du
pain perdu lendemain matin et de nos
jours on zappe tout c'est pas évident
d'inscrire une histoire non pas dans la
durée parce que si on n'a pas droit de
citer de marque mais dans le couple et à
partir de là lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
à partir d'une heure on est tous là en
fait à zapper en permanence séverine et
pas assez grande
on zappe de séverine non il faut garder
séverine avec sa taille de lolita c'est
essentiel il faut inscrire une histoire
dans le temps c'est à dire que si vous
vous droguez si vous voulez en parler il
faut aimer c'est vrai y compris avec ses
défauts bien avec ses fantômes j'ai
compris avec ses névroses alors c'est ça
une victime volontaire de la vie en
couple c'est elle qui elle concédé fond
mais voilà mais voilà tu veux pas du
tout
[Applaudissements]
il a 30 ans raconte la vue de cinq
heures de 30 en mai et qui empêche le
plan joint leurs amis de ra à courir non
ah ouais tu mettrais 2h toi alors on va
prendre quelques hommes parmi parmi les
cinq que vous décrivez nicolas rey ya
franck alors vous avez une phrase qui
est très jolie d'ailleurs en parlant de
francs maudite lévis sont ainsi faites
elles tiennent le coup des décennies
entières puis bascule sur un baiser et
c'est vrai qu'il a il est heureux il est
en coupe justement des puits rencontre
une femme il sait que ça va être
voilà c'est ça va être une catastrophe
il y va quand même c'est comme ça on a
la sensation parfois d'accéder à une
certaine sérénité une certaine
tranquillité d'avoir enfin trouvé un
équilibre
et puis d'avoir enfin quelques
certitudes
et puis c'est pas du tout prévu tu te
réveille un matin et puis tu croise
quelqu'un et sur un baiser toute ta vie
va basculer tu dois faire encore et
parfois comme ça le temps se rétrécit
sur quelques sur quelques secondes quoi
il va pas faire tel corps de l'un mais
c'est vachement bien sont très courtois
doller et et donc des roquettes craque
pour cette gonzesse
ouais mais ça c'est en fait il ya un
film de hal hartley cap a très bien
marché mais qui était très bien qui n'a
pas très bien marché
3 cd sort les gens n'osent pas ils ont
ce film qui marche verte avancé qu'un
film qui a eu un grand succès d estime
de saignée qui va devenir culte bien
débuté oui en dvd qu'un film de hal
hartley mais il ya d'autres films qui
vont avoir ce même destin et s'appelle
le titre c'est reste me et est en fait
l'histoire de francs que ça vient de là
c'est qu'à un moment dans le trust me le
héros du film tombe amoureux comme ça
alors qu'il est marié que sa vie un peu
rangé comme ça dans dans une armoire
comme dans un com le bonheur parfois
rangés dans une armoire et puis comme
août un an elle est la vie rangée dans
une valise et mollo est en fait et en
fait donc il ya ce truc là et le type
dit à la jeune fille
dans ce monde il ya deux choses les
ennuis et le désir 1
le problème c'est que à partir du moment
où tu commences à désirer quelqu'un sait
les ennuis qui commence voilà donc voilà
c'est ce qui arrive à franck en fait
tant qu'il n'avait pas désiré quelqu'un
et c'est à ce moment là où les
emmerdements commence alors lui il
craque complètement sur elle elle l
aimait les plus jeunes que lui
hélas cette phrase qui correspond à
transmis il faut avoir un peu confiance
ouais c'est joli il ya elle qui a eu
tant de moins qui lundi peut avoir un
peu confiance
il ya vincent si vincent pas on va sans
livres célibataire il redevient
sénateurs en vie devient grave
son bouquin j'en suis sûr et on le dit
en rigolant je pense que les gens sont
morts de rire chez eux
le bouquin va très bien il redevient
célibataire mais la vie lui fait
ex-pilier le choix de sa liberté
en fait ils rencontrent enfin moi elle
s'appelait je me souviens plus du nom
[Rires]
bénédicte selena n'est pas bénédicte et
merci ça fait 10 ans victime de l'avion
tu vois que tu allais légumes à sa façon
en fait non
durand devient maçon dumas pas
célibataire c'est lequel vincent devient
célibataire alors d'un sens retour on va
l'appeler cécile parce que sicile après
tout c'est un bon coup
cécile déjà 500 micola ba s'en retrouve
cécile oui voilà qui est dans la chambre
et le colonel moutarde
[Applaudissements]
c'est simple pourquoi parce que vincent
retrouve en fait
cécile cécile et son premier amour son
premier amour en classe de cm1 quand il
vient du théâtre comme souvent quand on
est enfant on fait du théâtre bien sûr
mais bien sûr voilà donc et en fait
c'est son premier amour à jamais disparu
donc c'est toute la thématique de courir
à 30 ans voyez-vous ce que je veux dire
c'est pourtant ça c'est à dire que on
passe son temps à courir quand on est
enfant par exemple quand quel âge at on
enfants je ne sais pas trois ans et demi
bas voilà à 3h30
il marche
[Applaudissements]
j'ambitionnais des gens très bien lui il
accepte le mariage avec vous avez ce mot
terrible
la détestation de l'autre vous pensez
que dans tout couple dans tout mariage
il ya forcément une détestation de
l'autre pas j'espère pas de façon comme
ça continue elle met de temps à autre
dans un des grands moments de m moi
étant out dans un lit tu te couches avec
ta femme tes à quelques millimètres
d'elle et pourtant il ya un océan qui te
sépare d'elle vas et tu la vois là mais
c'est la règle du jeu il faut l'accepter
il faut accepter de détester l'autre si
c'est un bon début c'est comme la
dépression nerveuse il faut accepter
d'aller mal c'est pas une si mauvaise
chose il faut accepter de faire un bide
au cinéma c'est un bon début oui on va
pas s'en sortir ne vais pas terrible et
des phrases sur la fidélité est une
vertu qui s'exerce par défaut france a
dans ta gueule qu'est ce t'en dit sa
hâte en laisse lui un peu de temps dans
trois mois dans trois semaines un autre
personnage louis que les baby sitter
d'une gamine de 11 ans qui lui saute
dessus pour l'embrasser fort en fait
c'est l'histoire d'un pédophile qui ne
l'est pas puisque comme j'écris
d'encourir à 30 ans il y à quelques
mètres de la rubrique des faits divers
mais ne monte pas dans la chambre de
clara et c'est ce qui m'intéressait
c'est la différence entre les nous est
ce qu'on appelle un meurtrier un aspect
encore un pédophile un monstre qu'est ce
qui nous distingue à un moment donné
nous de ces gens-là qu'on donne enfin en
peinture en pâture je cherchais le mot
exact
ouais c'est ça en pâture donc voilà
c'est parfois c'est une feuille de
papier à cigarette donc c'est ça qui
m'intéressait c'était de raconter ça
quoi voilà alors les piles tu suis là
j'ai repris je vais te féliciter les
gars là voilà paul et les autres auront
les pilotes
l'auteur à 70 ans il ya cette phrase
terrible écrire est un métier aussi
dégoûtant qu'un autre
un métier où plus personne n'a le choix
il faut aller aux signatures il faut
faire semblant d'écouter les gens qui
parlent de tes livres
il faut être capable de faire commerce
de sa vie privée pour dix mille
exemplaires de plus l'époque modiano est
terminée c'est fini écrivait alors non
parce que le fils répond non c'est toi
qui t'es corrompus c'est toi qui qui a
choisi le père du nom je n'avais pas le
choix à ce moment là il fallait il
fallait faire commerce de sa vie privée
pour vendre dix mille exemplaires de
plus et est en fait le fils lui dit on a
toujours le choix y compris de ne pas
faire commerce de ce à quoi
voilà donc non je pense que c'est pas
fini loin de là et heureusement
d'ailleurs
la preuve le clézio se vend très bien en
ce moment donc non c'est plutôt une
bonne chose mais je jeu en même temps
évidemment dernier chapitre c'est
c'était une façon à moi de pouvoir
raconter ce que j'avais vécu depuis mes
premiers livres
c'est à dire que j'ai aussi joué sur le
fait de faire commerce un peu de ce que
j' étais quoi et de ma vie privée est
souvent à attaquer ou poser des
questions là-dessus
et puis j'avais envie d'en parler parce
que c'est du bien d'en parler
non mais c'est en fait la promo c'est un
truc marrant là on rigole et tout mais
dans trois mois quand ça sera fini sa
trempe très triste tu te dis mais
jusqu'où je suis allé pour vendre mon
livre est vraiment il fallait faire ça
ou pas bah voilà ça va plutôt bien aux
médias cool on a rigolé non c'était cool
mais non mais c'est un vrai truc bien
sûr c'est normalement c'est les gachères
que tu vends mon garçon c'est clair mais
normalement un écrivain c'est déjà assez
chiant kaout de faim de passer deux ans
à faire du mieux possible pour faire un
livre
et en plus après il faut il faut
vraiment mouillé sa chemise
mais c'est vrai
deux arrêts 30 ans s'est évité au diable
voleur
à mes yeux
[Musique]
et maintenant
[Rires]
et les propos des bâtons
c'est jean michel cousteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean michel cousteau soir bonsoir bon
service ferrer nicolas rey laurent
baffie jean michel cousteau qui est donc
le fils aîné du commandant cousteau
voilà alors séverine pendant l'émission
si tu as du mal à suivre
si tout va bien tu es comme ça et si ça
va mal tu fais comme ça voilà c'est tout
comme ça il a l'habitude si tu manques
d'air qui fait comme ça alors jean
michel cousteau vous publier mon père le
commandant à l'archipel avec cette
extraordinaire photo de couverture au
moment où à l'âge de 7 ans votre père
comme vous dites vous jette à la baille
et c'est vrai que c'est une photo que
j'adore parce qu il ya dans le regard
quelque chose d'à la fois confiant et
anxieux c'est magnifique s'est souvenu
de 141 souviens très bien de toutes ces
années avec mon frère qui était plus
jeune qui lui avait été poussé par
dessus bord il avait 4 ans et demi et
puis on nous emmener pendant les
week-ends pendant les vacances sont
allés se baigner nager plonger alors que
nos petits camarades d'école où il
allait à la montagne et du ski
on pensait que c'était tout à fait
normal donc si vous voulez jules
privilèges
un des trains des premiers grâce à
mettre à l'eau alors ensuite pendant 40
ans
effectivement vous avez sillonné les
mers à bord de la calypso pour réaliser
votre rêve construire des maisons sous
la mer ou de nerfs jtekt vous avez
j'avais fait des maisons sous la mer
n'ont jamais non j'attends toujours mon
premier client
lepage à breslau et puis vous avez
réalisé produit de nombreux films
évidemment consacré à l'océanographie à
l'environnement alors votre livre
commence par l'enterrement du commandant
cousteau a beaucoup de livres qui
commence pour des enterrements
le livre de nicole calfan enterrement
autres films aussi annette vadim
enterrement la comtesse aux pieds nus
oui effectivement enterrement et elle
apprend raconte la vie voilà et là c'est
le début d'une fin voilà c'est un bon
truc c'est le 30 juin 1997 notre dame de
paris
des funeral quasi nationale
en présence du président la république
pour le fameux commandant cousteau
l'homme au bonnet rouge
et là on voit la veuve du commandant
francine avec ses deux enfants francine
qui la deuxième épouse donc du
commandant cousteau
vous vous citez jamais son prénom dans
le livre pourquoi parce que je pense que
c'est un personnage qui n'appartient pas
vraiment à l' aventure cousteau à
d'accord c'est pour ça que vous ne citez
pas son prénom tout laventure cousteau
s'est arrêté en fait si vous voulez le
jour où ma mère est morte ma mère je
dédie ce bouquin à ma mère ce qui veut
dire que sans ma mère le commandant
cousteau n'ont jamais été ses invités et
le jour de sa mort prématurée
mon père s'est liquéfiée littéralement
et à ce moment là vous repensé au
deuxième mariage du commandant quand il
a épousé 7,7 francine et en fait il
n'avait pas le droit de se marier deux
fois l'église parce que ça c'est
parfaitement interdit alors voulu poser
la question est en fait il vous répond
que grâce au révérend père carré il a
obtenu le droit de se marier deux fois
et vous découvrez que quand on est
académicien finalement ça ça aide
moi j'ai trouvé ça choquant ça le
regarde s il était en paix avec lui-même
1 ceci étant personnellement je trouve
ça très choquant mais c'est assez dur
quand vous le décrivez à genoux la
langue pendante pour recevoir l'hostie
c'est assez violent quand même ces
violences ce sens que s'ils voulaient
j'étais absolument choquée de voir mon
père qu'il ne pratiquait pas d'un seul
coup se liquéfiait littéralement parquet
pour le commandant cousteau et non ça
fait deux fois que vous dit ça s'est
amplifié ces sens bien alors son premier
mariage le commandant cousteau c'est
avec votre votre mère donc on a beaucoup
dit que c'était un beau mariage qui à
l'époque était quand même une façon de
dire que c'est un maillage d'argent non
non ce n'est pas un mariage d'argent
c'était un mariage d'amour qui en
l'occurrence a permis à ma mère qui
rêvait d'être dans la marine
à l'époque les femmes n'avaient pas
droit des dans la marine et de ce fait
elle a fait ce qu'il y avait de mieux à
faire c'était dans d'épouser un un marin
aujourd'hui qu'à lui ça lui a permis de
pénétrer dans le milieu des affaires
comme un salut a permis aux résidents
ça lui a permis d'ouvrir des portes
ouais alors quand votre belle mère
francine cousteau était sur ce plateau
on lui a parlé évidemment des
accusations d'antisémitisme dont votre
père a été victime
et cette fameuse lettre de 1941 le
commandant cousteau vient d'arriver à
marseille
il a une famille une femme et enfants il
n'arrive pas à se loger est il écrit une
lettre en disant il n'y aura
l'appartement convenable que quand on
aura fichu à la porte tous les ignobles
loutres qui nous encombre alors moi j'ai
découvert ça comme vous il ya deux ans
ou trois ans j'avais jamais entendu mon
père avoir des commentaires de ce genre
là je trouve ça extrêmement regrettable
bien sûr c'était une lettre privée qui
était destiné aux commandants tayeb qui
a qui a été
trouvez distribués mais il faut se
mettre dans le contexte de l'époque nous
étions quatre dans une chambre à
marseille au sixième étage et on pouvait
pas avoir de logement alors que les
réfugiés qui venaient d'un peu partout
eux auront leur donner des appartements
de plusieurs pièces dont il ya eu 1
souley a ras-le-bol il ya eu un geste
malheureux de sa part est regrettable
est que je condamne voilà alors après le
passage de votre belle mère dans cette
émission on a reçu un mail le fils d'un
ancien collaborateur de votre père qui
l'accusé d'avoir déposé à son nom
cette idée de détendeur qui a fait sa
fortune des entendu qu'il avait piqué un
certain emile gagnant alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ce détendeur c'est
quelque chose d'énorme c'était la fin du
gros scaphandre donc c'était une avancée
extraordinaire le le beau père de mon
père qui était un officier de marine qui
travaillait pour l'air liquide après sa
retraite avait mis en contact mon père
avec un ingénieur de l'air liquide
ouais et ses têtes emile gagnant pour
améliorer un système qui existait déjà
qui avait été inventé par le commandant
le prieur et avant le commandant prieur
qui avait été inventé par les roucayrol
denayrouze à espalion dans l'aveyron a
donné ce détendeur votre père il l'a
piqué ou une la radio il a appliqué du
tout il a ils ont adapté tous les deux
ainsi vous regardez le brevet ça
s'appelle cousteau gagne en pro b
cousteau gagnant donc lhi décembre où
les autres gagnants à gagnant 40 perd
l'idée a été partagé entre les deux et
vous pouvez parler à la fille de
monsieur gagnant qui toujours vie à une
femme extraordinaire d'ailleurs avec qui
j'ai plongé a pas très longtemps et il
n'y a jamais eu d'amertume à ce niveau
là en tous les cas pour pouvoir faire
les essais de son détendeur votre père
donc le commandant cousteau a fait appel
à son frère qui à l'époque était quand
même un personnage haut placé de la
france collaborationniste c'est pierre
antoine cousteau rédacteur en chef de je
suis partout journaleux fasciste et
d'ailleurs pierre antoine a été condamné
à mort à la libération il a été gracié
donc n'était pas antisémite mais enfin
c'est quand même servi de son frère qui
était un ponte de la collaboration pour
faire avancer son idée de détendeur je
ne sais pas exactement comment ça s'est
passé j'étais beaucoup trop jeune
là encore et je n'étais même pas à paris
j'étais à megève donc je je ne suis pas
un témoin direct et je n'en connais pas
vous allez leur perplexité perplexe
parce que je voulais parce que c'est la
vérité parce que votre père quand il eu
besoin de faire ces essais dans la marne
il a il a demandé d'autres villes a
demandé à son frère ce qui était logique
vous me direz d'une certaine façon
enfin sauf que cela n'avait absolument
rien à voir avec la position que pouvait
avoir son frère qui était mon oncle que
je n'ai pratiquement pas connu parce que
soit il était en prison soit il était
malade il est mort du cancer très jeune
après avoir être libéré et si vous avez
besoin d'un renseignement vous avez
besoin d'une permission vous allez voir
les gens qui peuvent vous la donner ça
absolument rien à voir avec la position
politique ou antisémite éventuelle de
son frère un patois éventuelles à venir
répondre mais quand on dirige je suis
partout pendant la guerre de 40 c'est
pas éventuel l'antisémitisme non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que je peux pas
vous répondre là dessus parce que je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est vraiment passé
alors autre reproche couramment adressé
à cousteau et que vous abordez dans le
livre c'est le fait d'avoir maltraité
des animaux et des le monde du silence
on parle de quelques cachalot sacrifié
en fait pour une reconstitution il ya eu
il ya deux choses dit il ya eu un
accident un accident où effectivement la
calypso est passé sur un bébé cachalot
hélas aussi sonné ce qui a été
absolument dramatique et il ya eu des
reconstitutions qui ont eu lieu plus
tard avec d'autres animaux n'oubliez pas
que nous étions des pionniers on faisait
les erreurs que font tous les pionniers
qu'on peut nous reprocher aujourd'hui
mais ça nous a appris ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire ouais et vient aussi les lions
de mer la pépite au et cristobal lapébie
temps et cristobal pareil et
sont morts qua non pas s'il y en a qui a
été empoisonné par une enquête impôts
bulls et cristobal oui un poids zones
est et l'autre qui a été mis sur une île
été relâchés au pérou alors qu'il vient
de madagascar mais tout ça c'est de
l'histoire ancienne si vous voulez et et
du non excusez mon cheminement et
j'espère qu'on va aller on va aller là
le président mans c'est qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces cinquante ans
ouais si vous quand même pas oublier que
le commandant cousteau et son équipe ont
fait connaître la mer à la terre entière
et que peut-être après l'abbé pierre et
le général de gaulle
c'est le personnage le plus connu sur
les prés le personnage français le plus
connu sur la planète
donc il ya une raison une raison quand
même dans le positif
tu sais tout ça toi non mais sinon toi
séverine tu aime tout ce qui est
langoustines crevettes rtas et
bigorneaux les bulots les les prêts ce
même siècle élan tu es déjà dans un âge
elle quitterait géant devant vous se
ferait au progrès on parvenait pas de
physique on a dit oui alors les élans
lustres les processions des langoustes
et la procession de langoustes comme les
crevettes et communes et un requin ce
sont les éboueurs de la mer vous vous
régaler avec des raisins et les crabes
des animaux qui les croient masse les
morts les blessés et mal formés qui sait
les landes et les homards les crabes les
araignées sont les langues on va aussi
aller omar aussi oui et les huîtres
alors parlons pas des huit avants
filtrauto tout cas celle de la mairie ni
manger tout en plus pas vendangé un
poisson vous enlevez loin est le coeur
le foie à la une huître ou quand j'ai
tout beau père était pas tendre avec les
animaux on vient de le voir mais pas non
plus avec les gens ils étaient très
durement à sa descente et dur parce
qu'ils étaient très déterminés ils
savaient vous voulez aller et
dans la mesure du possible rien ne
l'arrêté ouais ouais c'était aussi bien
avec sa famille qu avec des gens qui
l'entourent avec vous il a été terrible
avait ouvert un truc qui s'appelait le
cousteau fidji island resort qui
s'appelle maintenant que jean michel
cousteau
c'est un complexe touristique dans le
pacifique sud et si vous avez un procès
sans même vous appeler il m'a intenter
un procès m'a pas fait un procès à
intenter un procès qui a été arrêté et
j'ai mis mon nom mon prénom devant mon
nom toute ma vie moi j'avais fait du
cousteau et puis d'un seul coup dont
j'ai eu l'honneur de mettre mon prénom
devant oeuvre ceci étant vous savez
malheureusement à l'époque où ça ça
s'est passé alors que mon père m'avait
dit tu sais les avocats il faut jamais
se mettre de l'impact parce que c'est
eux qui gagnent et les autres perdent
toujours
asseyons-nous autour d'une table avec
une bonne bouteille de pinard et on
règle tous nos problèmes
1 et bien malheureusement il ya eu des
gens au milieu qui ont interféré à une
époque oui oui commençait à vieillir et
ça s'est mal passé c'est devenu très
public mais je peux vous dire qu'il ya
donc une amertume d'un côté comme de
l'autre cas c'est parler après et j
michel c'était francine qui le je ne
peux pas vous répondre à cette question
parce que je n'ai pas je n'ai pas si
vous voulez de preuves tangibles
d'accord bien en tous les cas votre
livre est évidemment un hommage à votre
père mais sa statue sera même dit peu
ébréché tout ça non quand même non je
pense pas je pense tout un personnage
absolument extraordinaire qui nous a
appris beaucoup de choses et je lui en
suis très reconnaissant il ya quand même
des été dur il a comme une scène
terrible à un moment votre frère
philippe un accident d'hydravion son
corps tombent dans le tages ont retrouve
son corps et au moment d'aller le
reconnaître à la morgue
votre père n'y va pas et vous envoie
vous va nous on attend du commandant
cousteau qui lie à et qu'ils soient
courageux enfin voila c'est captain
planet quoi et
il n'y a pas le captain planet avait une
tendance à déléguer tout ce qui était
désagréable
ouais et en l'occurrence ça a été très
dur pour moi et j'avais fait pour vous
c'est terrible de l'art j'obéis aux
commandants et ensuite c'est quand même
beau frère votre mère comme parce que le
héros principal du bouquin c'est votre
mère enfin cessé à merci bah oui de me
le rappeler bien sûr c'est si j'avais
écrit un livre sur ma mère 1
et il ya d'autres gens qui ont essayé je
ne serais pas là ce soir
or comme j'ai je présente mon père qui
est connu tout le monde ça me permet
d'une façon détournée de vraiment
maintenant voilà excusez moi mais à un
moment votre mère est malade à la fin
elle est victime d'un cancer généralisé
l'état monaco il s'en occupe pas
beaucoup il débarque là la veille de sa
mort elle a attendu qu'il fasse surface
si j'ose dire oui pour s'éteindre dans
ses bras
[Musique]
alors jean michel cousteau mon père le
commandant s'était dit et à l'archipel
et maintenant on va faire comme votre
père on va s'amuser avec les poissons
on va faire un quiz un quiz fiche
non
vous allez vous opposez tous les deux
assauts locaux isli souhait alors
attention
qu'est ce qu'une astéries étoiles de mer
bon
alors attention que se passe-t-il
laurent concentre toi
concentrez-vous jean-michel que se
passe-t-il quand on casse une branche
des toiles de mer elle repousse bon mais
demandait si c'était un piège
je suis méfiant mais pas des espèces
comptes et des points régis serge s'il
vous plaît pour le moment ça fait un
partout
attention jean michel laurent combien de
coeur à une pierre roy bravo quel animal
à près de 9000 dans le requin non non la
lamproie non quel animal à plus de 9000
dans c'est vrai quoi
je ne sais pas mais pourquoi tu sais pas
parce que j'ai pas encore l'animal qui
vit à la réunion un animal marin un
animal marin mais là on est dans le fish
quiz coelacanthe non non non mais donnez
votre langue au chat
pourquoi parce que c'est le poisson-chat
world
c'est un poisson chat parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d après son achat d'accord
attention quel est l'animal qui a le
plus grand cerveau au monde c'est kg 2
pour un animal de 15 mètres de long je
vais vous citer quelques requins vous
allez me dire celui qui n'existe pas
rejoignez alors maroni sexy
le requin taupe le requin taureau le
requin zèbre ou le requin chèvre lequel
n'existe pas c'est bon non cher c'est
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel allons-y à combien de temps
vit un esturgeon s'entend non
quatre-vingt dix ans non 81-60 n'en
parle à 110 en on attend 150 non ça ne
m'était pas aux enchères c'est moi
trente ans personne n'a répondu
un esturgeon jeudi jusqu'à son temps et
d'argent j'étais comme c'est vrai c'est
vrai à me donner un de mes points
un demi point pour jean michel et moi je
persiste à dire que ça vit plus
longtemps que ça ça peut vivre jusqu'à
100 ans un esturgeon avant on est dans
la volga tout ça il ya des spécimens de
trois mètres mali de ceux qui sont dans
les boîtes non malo très intéressant
quelle est la longueur moyenne d'une
bits de baleines en érection de massy
ainsi permis de mettre 40 travaux dit de
l'autre
exactement 2 mètres 40
excusez moi mais pour tous ces pièges et
y est pas non j'étais je n'étais pas
tout à fait à la longue c'est un peu
court dans la baie dans la vie vous avez
dit dans la bible habite de excusez-moi
jean-michel on parlait de quelle espèce
parce qu'il y en a des partis des plus
grand ce domaine attendait il faut il
faut quand même il faut quand même pas
charrier parce que vous êtes vous avez
des petites baleines les grandes
baleines
si vous prenez une baleine bloqué
l'animal le plus grand qui ait jamais
existé sur la planète yoga qu'elle
apprend pas de long way et bien sa dette
encore plus grand que ce que vous nommez
ses ordres c'est à dire j'ai vu des deux
mètres j'ai vu plein de gérer des deux
mètres et où j'ai visé deux mètres parce
que quand vous avez bien que quand quand
je vois quand vous avez un jeune mâle
qui est en train d'apprendre à faire
l'amour et que un vieux mâle est là pour
l'assister et une femelle au milieu de
tout ça et bien vous et c'est vous et
c'est verges extraordinaire de très
belles qui sait jamais
absolument remarquable et qui ballot
j'avais un ingénieur du son absolument
extraordinaire effondré qu'ils étaient
fatigués après une journée épuisante on
était tous dans un zodiac en train de se
balancer elle lit dans une petite voix
des verges sur la gauche et est tout de
suite et caméras en branle
c'est non quel est le point commun entre
un mérou une dorade grise et un poisson
à mes mots changent de sexe - ils sont
trop sexuel avec ces poissons il y en a
beaucoup d'autres espaces il y en a qui
deviennent un mal il ya leurs vieilles
deviennent femelles et c'est une
histoire de deux qui dominent quoi mais
vous pouvez pas savoir quel est le sexe
d'un de ces poissons hein
et quand vous êtes en présence par
exemple dames et roue et on la filme
mais j'ai des photos qui vous met qu'il
ya un verrou qui fait 120 kg à peu près
il agit qui vous met comme une loche qui
vous mettent leur sexe sur la tête ce
qui m'est arrivé et qui vous pousse
jusqu'au fond et qui vous écrasent bros
on se pose des questions
qu'est ce qu'un pieuvre argonauts et
détonnant pour se reproduire avec son
tentacules elle met le son
spermatozoïdes son sperme dans dans la
guilde des tentacules de la petite pièce
va mettre sur des tâches chargé de
sperme et part à la recherche d'une
femelle spermatophores et tomates au
sort
quel est l'autre nom du carassins doré
auquel est l'autre nom du carré saint do
ré sais pas ce que c'est qu'un carassins
d'abord nicolas l'autre nom du gars à st
de sardines c'est pas loin c'est un
poisson très simple la rascasse non j'ai
très très simple le gobie n'est pas le
gommer non alors c'est le poisson rouge
jean-michel pourquoi jean michel
pourquoi la mer est bleue les bleus à
cause de la réfraction de la lumière
bravo laurent pourquoi la mer rouge et
rouge
elle est rouge à cause du du plancton
qui la color ou du sel
elle est rouge oui elle parce qu'elle
contient des toxines et des chaires d
nord des dés et les rousses il contient
des des non non non les crevettes des
algues microscopiques
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est lorsqu'elle est le score 6 3
je suis désolé jean michel vous vous
êtes fait torcher parleront de la fille
quand même voix jean michel cousteau mon
père le commandant s'est évité alors si
belle
[Musique]
non je te félicite hu a été exemplaire
vraiment ça m'a fait plaisir
il adore ce salon est ce que vous êtes
libre
yes non mais elle cherche un expert non
mais il est bon franchement à chaque
fois on est en ce moment en train de
suivre des baleines que nous avons
marqué avec des bouées satellite et on a
besoin d'experts n'a besoin de gens qui
savent de quoi il s'agit vous êtes prêts
je suis prêt je pars demain laurent ça
tombe bien chez libre soit moche et pas
de nom
j'y vais moi ça la vie peut basculer ce
qu'il n'y a pas que ma vie était aussi
le mal de mer s'est pour sa part à des
pilules
non ça c'est plus un problème
extraordinaire bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si jean edouard lipa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans edwards
jean-edouard j'ai bien dit li pas parce
que ce soir ce n'est pas le lofteur que
nous recevons mais le comédien mesdames
messieurs et on l'applaudît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui peut m'aider
trois ans après l' aventure du premier
loft sur m6
jean-edouard vous avez décidé de prendre
votre carrière en main et de vous lancer
à fond dans le métier d'acteur
après des cours au studio pygmalion vous
avez décroché votre premier rôle et vous
serez à partir du 16 avril sur scène à
l'espace pierre cardin à la fiche de
jésus lacaille avec marie laforêt c'est
une pièce de francis carco adapté par
frédéric dard mari joue fernande et vous
bat le rôle-titre jésus lacaille le rôle
d'un prostitué homosexuel
voilà comme quoi le loft mène à tout mon
cher ami
voilà je regardais à dieu tu te souviens
de jean-edouard évidemment voilà je
regardais le loft j'ai regardé les trucs
qui étaient considérées comme les pires
à chaque fois j'ai regardé le loft 1 le
loft 2 1 et nice people donc vraiment
les endroits où ils ne font rien et je
trouvais ça plus intéressant que les
endroits où on doit vraiment devenir une
star de la chanson se faire ennuyé par
un prof de sport genre tiburce voie qui
fera manquent ils se quittent futur
c'est le prof de sport de la star
academy avoir tout pourri la vie
constamment et là j'aimerais bien côté
un peu totalement décadent il foutait
rien tu vas bon lui au début c'est un
peu amusé enfin tout le monde le sait la
première nuit quoi mais on va inventer
un détendeur
[Rires]
mais en dessous c'est vrai tout santé de
centaines l'ennui tu vas tu gagnais le
délabrement mais tu as raison il y avait
dans le premier loft et dans le deuxième
une dimension warholienne mais oui comme
le mec qui dort pendant huit heures dans
le tunnel à maurice et penser qu'à
bouffer plus ou moins car c'était une
sorte de délabrement moral et physique
au fur et à mesure et c'était vraiment
intéressant à regarder les voulez bien
montrer aussi fin et c'est pour bientôt
dire aussi que c'est monté que c'est
clair qu'on passait le plus grand ni du
coup j'ai encore pas mal de temps de lui
qui est fou amoureux de lui
ben alors et il est là d'ailleurs il
s'appelle louis l'anr il est haut et
chaussures il est là il est selon lui il
est là le wii wheel si bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir oui mais voilà écoute
franchement pas faire voilà qu'est ce
que tu fais dans la ville oui je suis
très content d'être invitée ce soir
c'est vraiment un grand bonheur pour moi
c'est vrai que je suis également auteur
dans la même maison d'édition que
nicholas ray mais c'est pas du tout pour
ça que je suis venu ici au diable
vauvert voilà sar un pur roman voilà
lancé oui mais voilà début mai c'est un
pur chef-d'oeuvre donc c'est vrai en
plus jean louis ce qui se passe avec
jean edouard
alors en fait on voulait compris je suis
pas du tout là pour ma promo absolument
pas je suis là pour faire une vraie
déclaration d'amour à jean edouard
également à séverine ferrer il aime
beaucoup séverine ferrer aussi les deux
c'est un petit peu un impact moi j'étais
très amoureux de séverine il ya des gens
il ya des gens qui sont bisexuels
l'huile est un peu ovni sexuée quoi il
est là au taquet tout le temps j'étais
très amoureuse tendre de séverine quand
elle avait 7 ans qu'elle a gagné le
concours de mini mini mini miss venus à
la réunion voilà c'est ça et ensuite ça
que vous avez un petit peu vieilli et
quand même c'est vrai nous a vus 8 9 ans
et c'est vrai que le regard des garçons
un peu changé sur vous et moi je suis
toujours resté fan de vous même et
internet et ap yahoo yhoo 15 à 15 et
maintenant vous en avez 16 ou 17 fâché
coup très bien et chez certains en même
temps je vais pas dire ça parce qu'en
même temps dans le livre de nicolas est
un personnage qui s'appelle louis qui
drague une jeune fille qu un onze ans et
je voudrais craquer dgd raccourci entre
moi et ce personnage rien avoir à bord
voilà comment on pourrait passer à tes
amours homosexuelles
jean-edouard regarde le regardent leurs
bras jean-edouard j'étais plus amoureux
de ta période en fait love story que ta
période comédien parce qu'en fait qu'il
représente pour moi la preuve que
n'importe qui peut s'incruster sur un
plateau télé et tenter de devenir une
star comme ça en trois minutes et c'est
vrai que j'avais trouvé une quinzaine de
cartes de bons clients par terre sur le
trottoir est-ce que je les amène est-ce
que je n'amène pas et finalement le plus
simple pour venir c'était de devenir
copains avec nicolas rey qu'est ce que
tu dirais d'une pause bisou qui te
permettrait à la fois séverine ferrer
est à la fois louis
comme disait le commandant je crois qu
on touche le fond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les airs
mouais
[Musique]
voilà donc après 7 pouces grises où l'on
se sent plus proches les uns des autres
on a partagé un moment ensemble on s'est
touché on s'est rapprochés on a envie de
jeter l'ancré
[Rires]
il faut mouiller avec des morues
il est génial c'est jean-michel vraiment
et baffie fais gaffe il a expliqué ton
boulot tu t'y connais en poisson mais il
fait des bonnes vannes géant messieurs
cette semaine sur deux d'accord mais moi
j'aurai la carte des points sky et
indicateurs d'évaluation notre bateau là
moi je reste ici que super je suis bien
là donc louis non pilule moi vous lui
avez déclaré votre amour vous l'avait
embrassée nous pour rester là vous êtes
bien enfin sa sortie larve n'étaient pas
tous
bah oui il a l'esprit et tout c'est
juste là non mais quand on aime quand on
aime on a plus d'esprit assez ça quand
on aimerait un peu con comme disait joey
starr sacre et in iz l'amour non c'est
béatrice dalle qui disait en parlant de
joris père alors jean edouard oui le pic
jésus là et ça parle de quoi
jésus d'accueil c'est l'histoire en fait
un peu du milieu de la prostitution dans
les années 20 à montmartre à travers
l'idée d'un jeune prostitué homosexuel
c'est son amour qu'il a envers une
prostituée d'un certain âge ans qui
retrouve un peu un côté maternel et qui
est marie laforêt tout à fait voilà et
voilà l'histoire se passe à montmartre
dans le milieu des démarches loup
effectivement alors au départ marie
laforêt assez mal réagi elle vous
appelle vous dis mais enfin il faut pas
qu'on fasse cette pièce ensemble enfin
tu n'es pas comédien avant elle
m'appelait pour ça elle t'a appelé pour
ça oui mais c'est la seule fois où elle
m'a appelé c'était pour me dire écoute
je suis derrière toi quoi qu'on puisse
dire c'est pas parce que tu es né de la
real tv qu'on n'y arrivera pas moi je
trouve qu'il se trouve super donc
apparemment il ya pas qu un premier coup
de fil où elle s'inquiétait en disant il
veut le faire peut-être quelqu'un
d'autre mais en tout cas c'est comme
avant c'est pas toi annonce est un droit
non parce que moi la version que jc
quelques appels une première fois en se
disant c'est un coup de fric bon voilà
et qu'après ltte rappel en disant nous
ont finalement quand elle a vu ta
première réplique elle a dit tu joues
bien y'a pas de problème
le premier coup de téléphone je n'ai pas
eu assez trempé
bah oui elle s'est trompée le problème
c'est qu'à cause du loft été obligés
d'être excellent parce que c'est vrai
que ça c'est terrible on ne pardonnera
rien tu comprends pourquoi on te trouve
bon il faut que tu sois excellent jaurès
g et tu le sais bah ouais non parce que
le décès mais en même temps je le prend
plutôt bien c'est plutôt logique parce
qu'on a commencé à être connu avant
d'avoir fait quelque chose donc
logiquement canton
les choses vont un peu plus vite donc si
on est moyen on est mauvais si on est
bon les moyens est très bon on est moins
correct voit donc on essaye d'être très
bon quand même
il faut que tu sois très bon bah ouais
je fais un tout cas je fais tout pour
alors tu dis j'en ai assez que l'on
pense que je n'ai rien dans la tête j'ai
quand même fait un an de droit et j'ai
un bts d'action commerciale d'antigel la
question n'est pas cool
pourquoi mais celui-ci une déclaration
qu'il a fait lui non c'est pas c'est pas
le fait d'avoir fait des études qui me
rendrait plus intelligents mais c'est le
fait que la télévision parfois rend les
gens un peu plus con c'est à dire que
vis-à-vis du public bas on enferme dans
une image ou untel est méchant
et pas uniquement pour les gens de la
télé réalité pour tout le monde intel
est méchant et ça va même jusque chez
les comédiens ou quand un comédien qui
joue tout le temps les rôles des bandits
vont finir par dire que c'en est un donc
c'est un moment où on a envie de
remettre les choses à leur place et
d'expliquer aux gens que c'est pas parce
que on a c'est une émission de télé
réalité qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
et qu' une certaine image et de vous a
été accentuée que obligatoirement
alsacien temps de paddy des études on a
juste dit un bts d'action commerciale
ce qui est terrible c'est que les gens
de la télé réalité ils ont du mal parce
qu'ils sont devenus célèbres avant
d'avoir fait quelque chose donc après il
faut nourrir cette notoriété c'est très
compliqué donc toi tu en es là et puis
surtout toi tu es devenu célèbre dans
cette scène bondues du loft avec loana
donc c'est vrai que d'un seul coup ça va
être difficile de faire oublier ces
populations dans la piscine le problème
des gens de latéralité pour certains
c'est nourrir la notoriété et moi mon
show n'était pas de nourrir la notoriété
mais de véritablement faire un travail
de fond et sur le long terme
donc c'est pour ça que depuis un certain
temps je me fais discret je me plains
pas non plus que tous les gens viennent
me voir pour revenir sur un plateau
parce que je pense que de temps en temps
vous me fermer sa gueule que parler pour
rien dire alors vous dites jean-edouard
avec loana nous n'avions pas conscience
de tourner un film porno notre contrat
stipulait qu'aucune scène de sexe ne
serait diffusé c'est vrai ça tout à fait
où est dans le contrat et est bien
stipulé que justement tout ce qui
pouvait toucher à la sexualité ne serait
pas diffusé donc bah moi je fais en
rajoute heures jeudi soir sous l'eau hop
y signer ici
niamey
quelque chose que je pense beaucoup
d'autres auraient fait et sans se
soucier que les kamas une mais parce que
pour nous il fonctionnerait pas à ce
moment là donc on a fait et puis voilà
est ce qui a été fait a été fait on a su
à ce qu'on vous a reproché c'est pas ça
parce que ça à la limite effectivement
tout le monde aurait été ravi de le
faire qui est censé passer gérable mois
ce lot il a changé de sexe
les palois jean michel non
jojo non mais ce qu'on vous a reproché
quand même c'est d'avoir laissé tomber
ouais c'est ça qui a quand même
handicapé vos chances de gagner c'est
que voilà on met quoi à loana je sais
pas moi ça s'est fait d'un consentement
mutuel et au départ oui mais après je
veux dire vous vous dites
bon on avait tous les deux envie de
tirer un coup puis le lendemain elle est
venue voir en disant qu'elle était
amoureuse qu'elle voulait se marier
bah ouais mais ça vous paraît pas
bizarre justement que une fille puisse
venir vous voir et vous dire j'ai envie
de me marier avec toi le lendemain un
truc pareil
bah ouais c'est moche quand on
s'accroche ou dans une telle situation
donc là c'est logique que je réagisse
comme ça je pense que beaucoup de monde
réagit de la même façon sans vouloir
faire de pub on est dans courir à 30 ans
la 17 euros au diable vauvert n'est rien
vraiment c'est ça la lâcheté enfin j'en
parle énormément n'en courir en temps
c'est ça c'est qu'est ce que c'est que
le guide de survie de nos joueurs du mal
de vivre masculin c'est aussi la lâcheté
comme la dépression comme l'ironie comme
des relais et c'est pas grave il ay là
il était dans l'instant quoi dans
l'instant la peau c'est un vient le voir
elle lui dit je suis amoureuse de toi
pourquoi on se marie pas huit parents
courent moins d'aller ça m'intéressait
pas donc en même temps j'ai été honnête
aller plus loin la lâcheté que de dire
se bat non ça m'intéresse pas d'aller
plus loin alors ensuite j'ai fait une
petite romance avec jennifer la star ac
c'est vrai c'était celle inverse dans la
célèbre est celle inverse c'est à dire
que là vous avez complètement craqué un
jean et doit l'être en vous dévoilant ce
qu'il faut jamais faire une demande à
nicolas qui est un spécialiste de l'âme
humaine vous le dira mieux que moi mais
c'est vrai il a écrit une lettre en se
dévoilant une lettre d'amour
elle lui a reproché son manque de
maturité tu vois ah ouais non je sais
pas s'ils n'ont peut-être pas peut-être
est-ce que à ce que donnait est ce que
quand on est moi je suis je suis le
genre de garçon qui quand je suis
amoureux jeudi tout tout de suite
pour beaucoup de gens c'est souvent un
manque de maturité que pour beaucoup de
gens il faut alors il faut aller il voit
une certaine n'a pas fait si sa logique
moi j'ai pas fait de cinéma comme jours
et voilà comme j'ai dit oh non ça
m'intéresse pas d'aller plus loin belle
j'ai dit voilà ce que je pense je dis ça
m'intéresse d'aller plus loin et quand
j'aime quelqu'un je lui dis je me cache
pas quoi donc ces êtres
c'est très mature je pense pas c'est
être honnête et dévoiler ses sentiments
je pense que c'est la meilleure des
choses à faire il est bien ce genre et
douala jean edouard a raison il faut
passer en sept ans pour tomber amoureux
des gens parfois voilà il était tombé
amoureux de jennifer vraiment tu l'a
écrit une lettre
ouais j'ai découvert s'est passée la
déception
non pas du tout non c'était une aide
parce qu un soir chez elle avait un soir
elle était en un endroit et elle m'a dit
j'ai envie de te voir et donc j'ai fait
le déplacement qui était comme un long
trajet et je suis resté juste une nuit
lendemain j'ai laissé une lettre avec
comme dans l'univers ce que je pensais
et
enfin voila j'ai enfin ça venait du
coeur et après la fait souffrir à lui a
posé des lapins ils ont échangé des
propos aigres-doux enfin ça s'est mal
terminée est-ce que vous avez souffert
jean-edouard bas je pense que quand on
aime quelqu'un et que ça se passe comme
ça ouais on en souffre au minimum donc
ne fait pas trop souffrir louis quand
même mais c'est encore lui ça va être
intégralement érotisme depuis jennifer
ya rien eu
non y'a rien n'y a rien eu depuis
jennifer fait d'autres filles mais pas
de l'aventuré monde aventures amoureuses
non juste mais la wii
là vous êtes concentré sur la pièce et
ouais ouais enfin c'est plutôt ça cette
aventure c'est le travail sur la pièce
sur quelle pièce jésus lacaille de carco
adapté par frédéric dard à l'espace
cardin à partir du 16 avril
voilà là vous vous concentrez sur marie
laforêt je me concentre sur la pièce et
sur l'ensemble des comédiens qui jouent
avec moi parce qu'une pièce je pense
qu'avant tout c'est une troupe ce n'est
pas juste un premier rôle est donc c'est
c'est partager enfin y'a pas une pièce
avec un acteur il ya une pièce avec une
troupe est donc ce soit le dernier
dernier commet le dernier rôle
le second rôle le premier rôle je pense
que chacun a son importance il a pris
tous les tics des comédiens ont déjà
pierre arditi c'est là menteur mais j'ai
souvent entendu déjà en faire le
reproche justement certains comédiens de
ne parler que d'eux quand ils font la
promo d'une pièce de théâtre mais je
pense qu'une pièce de théâtre avant tout
ce n'est pas un comédien c'est une
troupe est une pièce de théâtre et c'est
pas un seul comédien sur scène qui va
faire too much et les fruits de mer
c'est normal de citer tout le plateau
[Rires]
oui
thual ou alors c'est vrai j'aurais de
voir que vous êtes interdite de piscine
nord plus de 30 départements ça j'étais
pas au courant 2010 en même temps je
vais pas refaire les 32 avant c'était
moi
samedi la piscine
[Musique]
jean et loire vous avez refusé de
participer à cette cette chanson des
lofteurs way up and down
pourquoi parce que l'époque à vendre
parce que moi j'avais commencé le
théâtre j'avais 8 ans et donc mais pour
permettre de gagner ma vie à côté de mes
études j'ai été jetée dj est bon ou
mauvais quand je suis sortie du loft et
que j'ai voulu continuer là dedans en
attendant pour payer mais mes cours de
théâtre
j'ai dit bas
même si ce sera difficile gens ils me
faire à une crédibilité dans le milieu
de la musique électronique et j'ai
estimé que c'était pas en faisant un tel
titre que j'y arriverai voilà donc j'ai
préféré dire non alors que je suis sûr
que les gens sont incapables de les gens
pensent que vous il a fait mais moi
l'intérieur de savoir que je n'ai pas
fait j'en suis très fier leur est refusé
à peine dame ne vous n'échapperez pas
jean-edouard à une interview à peine d'
[Musique]
attention ce que vous préférez en vous
mon coeur ce que vous détestez en vous
on est tombé j'ai l'impression d'avoir
une bouteille à la place de génial j'ai
l'impression d'avoir sauvagement bien
tourner séverine tu n'aimes pas sonné
j'ai l'impression d'avoir un sac à linge
et de squales et des yeux d'algues ses
mains sont au gré des masses j'aurais
loire ce que vous préférez dans le
théâtre
les trois coups la troupe le partage
entre les comédiens les émotions qu'on
se donne et qu'on reçoit ce que vous
n'aimez pas du tout dans le théâtre
les tensions ce que j'ai l'impression
que malgré tout chacun ses petites
habitudes et rien avant et bas chacun ne
veux pas en changer et donc le tout
c'est parfois de savoir prendre sur soi
ou de savoir dire les choses clairement
le plus grand moment de votre vie le
sort de la générale le pire moment de
votre vie
le jour où mes deux grands parents ont
disparu et le taux d'intérêt en
l'occurrence pendant que ce qui vous
plaît le plus dans la vie
l'ambition le fait de savoir de vouloir
mettre tout ce qu'on a en soi pour pour
arriver à quelque chose qu'on s'est
fixés ce qui nous fait vraiment chier
dans la vie l'hypocrisie et tête de con
votre plus gros coup de fric plus gros
coup de fric
honnêtement alors là je crois que j'en
ai pas fait parce que toutes les fois où
on m'a proposé justement surtout après
le loft parce qu'avant j'étais m'a
proposé de st pas mal de choses et mon
plus gros coup de fric c'est d'avoir
refusé de faire lofteurs open hommes qui
avaient rapporté à chacun comme un gros
paquet de fric peu plus grosse perte
mes grands parents ouais votre plus
belle histoire d'amour
une jeune fille à l'époque où je
travaillais donc dans une discothèque
avec ce en provence avec qui je
travaillais j'étais tombé
follement amoureux d'elle et pareil
j'étais prêt à tout pour y arriver et
j'y suis pas arrivé le plus minable
histoire d'amour celle là aussi ouais
bah j'en ai avec 2 et les deux ont foiré
donc choisir faut trancher est-ce que
vous avez des plus sexy je sais pas
vraiment me faisais n'importe quoi je
sais pas d'un très beau cul quand même
c'est lui qui m'a est-ce que vous avez
deux mois sexy mon nez le prouve mais
qu'est ce qui va avec sont vraiment
aucun sens comme une obsession
louise lui et quelques jeunes et eu un
très joli nez jean edouard vous préférez
dans le sexe la levrette ce qui me
dégoûte dans le sexe ça existe la
chevrette
qu'est-ce qui me dit dantec j'ai pas
peur
c'est ce qu'indique ce que relative
des gouttes dans le sexe c'est certain
côté malsain qui peuvent être poussé
très loin
ouais vous j'irais pas tu aimes pas le
sexe mâle ça tout dépend ce qu'on
appelle massin pour les gens une
fellation ça peut être malsain et pour
d'autres coucher avec un cheval c'est
très malsain
ouais ça dépend quel cheval et marie
laforêt dont jésus la cale à l'espace
pierre cardin
et à partir du 16 avril
[Musique]
bon ben oui on va vous faire c'est
normal prochaine thierry la semaine
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
si victoria et david beckham
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
bon ça merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle surtout cette semaine le
tabloïd anglais parle de la crise au
sein de votre couple
katz à la haye on pourrait dire ça ils
ont écrit que david victoria vous aurait
trompé avec une ancienne jeune et jolie
assistante nommé rebecca luz qui a 25
ans savait ça c'est vraiment ça
complètement absurde ce temps raconte
plein de trucs sur nous dans la presse
et c'est presque jamais vrai fabrication
ouais enfin elle dit quand même qu'à
l'époque où victoria était à beckingham
palace à londres avec les enfants
là une aventure sexuelle avec vous à
madrid ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'est juste presse à sensation c'est pas
vrai en fait on dit aussi que victoria
chante bien c'est toi et ouais au coût
de alors le message sur vos portables
publiées par la presse et vendue par
cette rebecca luz 500 mille dollars sont
assez chaud quand même ça aussi vous
savez il ya des gens qui en profitent
surtout dans la presse
nous on est connue victoria et moi mais
tout ça ça va ça va être étouffé toute
façon toute façon on s'adore oui oui
vous avez déclaré david suite à ça je
suis marié et heureux ça suffit vous
pensé pour pour étouffer le scandale
bien sûr bien sûr l'amour est plus fort
que jamais entre nous et si on arrive à
surmonter ça ça ne rendra encore plus
fort ouais
jusque-là victoria elle dit nous avons
traversé des choses pires notre couple
va survivre à ça absolument
on s'adore et on est vraiment comme des
meilleurs amis au final quel sens y a
pas de confiance dans une relation il ya
vraiment rien et cette confiance elles
existent entre nous alors c'est
difficile victoria de garder l'homme le
plus sexy de la planète
j'ai mes moyens de le garder c'est ma
cuisine qui le retient alors au japon
les fans achètent des morceaux des draps
ou david beckham a dormi
est ce qu a madrid on achète aussi les
morceaux de bravoure avait dormi avec
rebecca de david mais y'a rien à acheter
est ce que dans est ce que dans le
public c'est des questions à poser à
victoria vous venez monsieur tient
méline va vous bien en dix mois qu'est
ce que tu as des questions à poser à
david ou victoria beckham
j'aimerais savoir comment david vit son
halo appelle des eaux là
doit savoir comment david avis on vit en
ce moment c est né à madrid la
statistique
madrid c'est vraiment sympa je me suis
vraiment installer la enfin dans pas les
critiques plutôt de critiques ce salon
on s'est bien débrouillé le début de la
saison ça se passe bien
vers la fin un peu moins bien mais
mais voilà je me sens bien j'adore jouer
dans cette équipe
plein de joueur que j'adore donc c'est
vraiment un rêve qui est devenu une
réalité qui ont tiré
qu'est ce que ça vous fait le staff et
démange toi ou sur les manches la partie
contre monaco d'engagement ya un
traducteur qui veut se faire aussi
non je jouais pas je souhaite pas
d'ailleurs
ouais l'équipe a perdu 8 à willows
monaco c'est sûrement une bonne équipe
merci est-ce qu'il ya d'autres gens
venaient mademoiselle profitez-en c'est
40 euros je voudrais poser la question
victoria savoir si l arrêter
complètement sa carrière de chanteuse ou
si toutefois le voir continuer encore si
elle va sortir un prochain album
qu'est ce que j'avais prévu en fait
c'était de sortir un album tout bientôt
mais j'ai aussi mes enfants je passer du
temps avec ma famille je vais m'occuper
de ça pour l'instant c'est un peu mon
programme donc je sortirai un indice
dans quelque temps sûrement très très
bien à vous moi je vais le revoir savoir
si c'était vraiment les beckham ce soir
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des cadres impliqués thierry hesse
contrôle de vos lunettes
[Applaudissements]
mais cgg officiel de beckham
alors est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est vrai on dit que vous n'avez pas le
droit de croiser david beckham que c'est
interdit
d'ailleurs moi je les ai rencontrés
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs j'ai été sa
doublure dans une pub quand david arrive
c'est vrai qu'il faut que je quitte le
plateau au valais dit qu'il veut pas me
rencontrer
il trouve que c'est bizarre hein et vous
vous avez le droit de croiser victoria
beckham j'ai fait du doublage pour elle
dans certains films et châtiment quand
je les rencontre il a été dit très sympa
ça n'a pas l'air de la déranger
particulièrement que je sois là on a
parlé elle est vraiment sympa croisé à
la gare victoria est ce que vous avez eu
en dit des menaces de mort déjà de gens
qui vous reprochez de de jouer le sosie
de david beckham
ça fait six ans qu'on fait ça maintenant
c'est un boulot à plein temps pour nous
et tout début quand on a commencé dès
vite tout le monde le détester parce
qu'il avait été
mais planté avec l'argentine et et c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des menaces de mort
quotidiennement on a même mis le feu à
ma voiture
c'était horrible un vrai cauchemar mais
bon on y recrute est de plus en plus
maintenant c'est encore plus un boulot à
plein temps donc c'est bien c'est bien
votre joueur préféré c'est qu'il vaut
toujours de foot préférée c'est un idée
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que camilla est ce que vous
chantez aussi mal que victoria à bien
faire non mais je me contente de chanter
sous la douche
c'est vrai que vous avez été reçu par le
le sosie de la reine d'angleterre
on a rencontré le sosie vous êtes
ensemble tous les deux on est meilleurs
amis beaucoup j'ai pas ensemble vous
n'êtes pas ensemble dans la vie tous les
deux camilla et andy non mais on est
vraiment des super amis mais vous avez
coché en commun à scanex non non non moi
ça marche pas comme ça chez moi on n'a
pas ça le french kiss baiser française
et nous ça se fait pas le fun donc la
langue et vous connaissez la largue aux
bisous vous connaissez ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci des new vais me chebbi
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant voici dolores chaplin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors est ce bon soir donc après le fils
du commandant cousteau la petite fille
de charlie chaplin
décidément ce soir ça va avec la fille
de michael chaplin voilà et de patricia
votre maman originaire de trinitad vous
connaissez ni pleurer non mais nous
paraît bien les terrains livre qui
s'appelle courir à 30 ans mais sa fin le
pitch bah oui il va faire le nom est
connu c'est pour rire parce que parfois
de le reste ça vous arrive d'être
moralement dans un état second voire
tertiaire de pas avoir trop le moral
oui oui alors lisez courir à 30 ans oui
je vais le lien ou non sa mère j'ai
regardé encore les 17 euros au diable
vauvert ce qui n'est rien qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que ces clés
de leur s c'est quoi ça déménage je ne
sais pas je me suis retrouvé que les
clés dans la main et je vais demander
pourquoi on avait fermé à clé mais on
verra donc y'a rien d'essentiel dans
sept lycées pour pouvoir l'ouvrir après
vous avez rien laissé d'extraordinaire
son sac peut-être oui avec son bec
peut-être un passé ouais ça va oui bon
je pense que vos parents l'a fait dix
cartes de crédit est à présent une carte
de bons clients
non je le tuerais
il vient de mon père jean edouard oui
c'est mon ami et mon ami le hamon
apporte avant je veux en donner une à
jean-michel pour des raisons
halieutiques
voilà l'enjeu non ma fille tu lui d'une
cale et mini alors cette carte là je
vous l'avais pas 100 euros je vous la
fait main 50 euros donnés - simplement
30 euros louis les nerfs à lui l'anr
pour 10 euros 30 euros 30 euros
oui vous 30 euros bouly 40 euros 60
euros 100 euros payables par hacker
vraiment car millénaire 10 euros on vend
les cartes de bons clients c'est une
aura et jean-edouard tu peux lyon pour
l'association mon pote tu y vas tu lui
donnes à la suite moi j'aime
responsabilité d'une comptabilité
apprendre du wat a jamais de bon coeur
faut dire non plus que j'ai vu ce qu'il
a fait à l'eau en armes le nord-est si
c'est une tradition tout le monde
s'embrasse
oui c'est quelque chose de très haute
tension tht a embrassé avec de ces
données pendant une demi seconde la john
wayne et thé chaud comme la braise
jaloux vient donc en parler des parents
jeu de leurs aises qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est vrai vous êtes jaloux on a eu
notre mamie tu t'es pas donné sa santé
lui parlant mariton fils est blanc non
mais faut voir aussi dans l'arrêté
marathon fils de ton accouchement c'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est je me sens
merci jean edouard
c'est gentil mais depuis tout à l'heure
je m'en occuperai bien donc je vais
essayer quand même de raconter un petit
peu la vie de dolores donc votre père
c'est mika chaplin votre mère c'est
patricia originaire de trinidad parents
un peu baba cool à faut le dire parce
que votre père par réaction contre son
père de charlie chaplin a été un petit
peu comme ça rebelles vous savez ce que
c'est jean-michel même il est un charlot
inventant vagabonde en france en espagne
en irlande à trinidad et un jour vous et
votre famille finissait par atterrir
dans le sud-ouest de la france dans une
ferme en ruine où vous vous nourrissez
tous des produits du potager et du lait
des chèvres
quel est votre père parce que votre père
est un éleveur de chèvres alors
évidemment à l'école personne ne veut
croire que de leur s est la fille de
michael chaplin et petite fille de
charlie chaplin parce que bon sang par
une caisse un peu pour havre qu'il avait
échangé contre deux chèvres c'est vrai
c'est vrai voilà c'est tout est-ce que
c'était une deux chevaux
non je sais pas s'il y avait plein de
stickers c'est parce que ça devait
appartenir à des jeunes gens dont un
truc comme ça c'est vraiment un titre ou
un phénomène son père il faudra attendre
la mort de votre grand-mère una pour que
vous alliez vivre au bord du lac léman
qui s'embrassent maison de charlie
chaplin voilà alors avant vous alliez
dans cette maison uniquement pour les
pour les vacances et vous avez pas tu es
mon souvenir en fait de charlie chaplin
à un vieux monsieur qui ont poussé dans
un dans un fauteuil roulant quoi voilà
est ce que vous faisiez le lien entre
lui à l'époque et le personnage en noir
et blanc des films muets non jamais
parce que
je sais pas c'est très séparés à tel
point que mon petit frère à un moment
donné penser que louis de funès était de
notre grand père il dit c'est monsieur
très drôle c'est mon grand père c'est ça
il comprend des très petites très jeunes
de l'aurès vous commencé à monter des
spectacles payants pour vos parents et à
quel âge 7 8 ans et les strip teaseuses
à quel âge 12 ans je sais pas si c'est
légal justement des strip-teases à 12
ans absolument pour vos parents n'ont
parents et leurs amis parents c'est
sympa la ferme dans le sud-ouest un
enfant dans tous les cas vous vous
commencé à rentrer comme ça dans le
monde du spectacle et aujourd'hui il ya
une chanson qui a énormément de succès
qui est une chanson on entend la voix de
votre votre grand père et qui s'appelle
modern times c'est à dire les temps
modernes
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire si c'est un morceau qui a
été remixé bien entendu mais autour de
la voix de votre grand-père mais non
c'est très mignon j'ai trouvé ça m'a
tout de suite plu
alors je trouve une anecdote très
marrante ce qui des femmes qui écrivent
à g-five qui demandent des posters de
charlot ouais c'est très très mixte qui
a refait sa dj choléra part ça fait
connaître vraiment à une autre
génération
je me rends compte qu'il ya vraiment une
génération qui connaît pas trop qui
connaît pas du tout en fait tu connais
ça ouais
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le clip de ce morceau reprend des images
de l'avant première du film à new york
en 1936 il a été réalisé par raphaël
frydman super metteur en scène et
c'était c'était comme un mini film
c'était non c'est être vous voulez qu'on
le voit là oui pourquoi vous regardez
votre caméra là wide rouge voilà et vous
dites
magnéto serge magnéto serge très bien
moi
[Applaudissements]
m
du coup
est ce qu'ils meurent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thierry figurines de l'europe
morgane kind c'est à dire les temps
modernes malin alors est ce que vous
savez que votre grand père a participé à
un concours de sosies de charlie chaplin
et qu'il a été recalé non c'est vrai
c'est historique
vous saviez pas ça il a été recalé
recalés un concours de sosies de charlie
chaplin c'est énorme c'est génial oui
venez ici je vous dirais détruit mon
sexe devient bien alors ben vous serez
pas étonné que je fasse une interview
cinéma muet
[Musique]
donc je ne veux rien entendre mais
entendu en vue dans le cinéma muet de
leur reste donc vous me regardez et vous
allez me faire la tête que vous faites
quand on vous pose sans arrêt les mêmes
questions sur votre grand-père - est pas
mal mais la tête que vous faites quand
on rit pas devant les films de votre
grand-père quand on vous reproche les
charlots la tête que font les gens chez
eux quand ils regardent c'est une tonne
[Rires]
la tête que vous faites quand on vous
dit que vous êtes ravissante questions
pense qu'il faut c'est bon la tête que
vous faites quand on vous dit tu fais
quoi après l'émission de la rai la tête
que vous faites quand on vous dit je
t'aime c'est par la lèvre pardon
jean-michel qu'est ce qu'il a
[Musique]
dolores regardez-moi la tête que vous
faites quand on vous propose de passer à
l'acte on avait à parlent pas le
français
la tête vous faites quand vous trouvez
que l'animateur est lourd
oui la tête que vous faites quand vous
pardonner à l'animateur d'être lourd
ouais la tête que vous faites quand on
sait la fin notre interview
la tête qu'elle fait quand elle dit je
t'aime à quelqu'un ouais elle dit je
t'aime à quelqu'un la tête que vous
faites dit je t'aime à quel point
nicolas nicolas nicolas
elle me fait super bien
[Musique]
ça va qu'il autres invités ce soir
et
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci pascal senn
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pascal simon soir
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui vous n'avez que des comptes en avoir
des amis si pascal sellem à commencer
par arrête toi même tu es bien la
twinair jean-michel voilà les oreilles
bien copains ça va ça va super bien
alors vous bossez pascal sellem à tf1
sur les sept péchés capitaux
est-ce que c'est par envie ou par
paresse les deux bravo non c'est la
première que je le vois je n'ai déjà en
plus des sept péchés capitaux vous
faites des caméras cachées voulait qu'on
cache les caméras là vous sentirez plus
à l'aise non non ça va ça joue la
famille ça vous dérange pas oui alors
pascal vous sortez les caméras cachées
que vous avez réalisé pour les sept
péchés capitaux
alors pour en vendre 1 million vous
savez ce qu'il faut faire la promo ouais
y avait pas de parti pris c'est un
bonheur vous regardez caméra et vous
dites magnéto serge serge magnéto ouais
comme monte à la grosse tête à magnéto
serge la cuisse doit cuit ouais tu te
fasses curatteau oui lapize arnaud
lapide la pizza si tu la prends je les
vends et de peexme kefu contient 30 à
pitre
à
allez soit sympa attend 3 pitt je dois
fais pas tu veux une [ __ ] je te refais
vu m'a fait mourir la pêche fraîche
ouais je sais pas j'ai pas d'argent mais
je les change voilà qui change c'est là
les restos du coeur ici ou qu un tu fais
ta pizza tu fais que tapie tu es tu veux
quoi aussi tu vas dimanche l'ump quand
tu peux prendre la table
fait je t'ai demandé tout le monde dit
oui comment ça que tu vas d'apprendre
quoi vous allez vous avec la table vous
me dites c'est apprendre la table ah non
s'il est sérieux rooster parce que j'ai
pas envie de rigoler aujourd'hui c'est
un mauvais jour mais moi je croyais que
vous prendrez la table pour nous avoir à
l'accord c'est pas prendre dans ce pays
moi je peux prendre la chose quand même
à la chaîne peinture d'accord merci
non non non footfoot à pitre occupe et
égorgée bon alors je peux pas parce
qu'il ya du chorizo ça pique
mais je m'en fous est égal
quoi côté bonne si vous voulez que je
sorte de carnet de timbres amendes n'ont
pas longtemps ça va ça va se trouver
encore plus leurs habits je vous bougez
votre véhicule
je peux la finir
maple a fini pour finir quoi ça parlait
oui vous rendiez immédiatement dans sa
méthode super bowl isme d'accord parce
qu'elle sait les caméras cachées
ces échecs habitants
bon moment alors et à une caméra cachée
finalement bon d'abord on veut trouver
l'idée ensuite faut tourner le truc et
tout mais le plus compliqué après c'est
demander les autorisations aux gens dont
c'est faux sacs à main qui sont floutés
c'est oui il y en a certains qu'on
flottille a certains qu'on peut pas du
tout m et qu'on a bien on aime bien les
maîtres excusé mais un exemple de
caméras cachées génial je n'ai pas pu
diffuser parce que le mec vous a pas
donné l'autorisation de diffusion non
non non parce que le mec le mec on a
envie qu'il passe dans ta caméra cachée
tu es obligé tu restes avec lui jusqu'à
ce qu'ils signent pendant deux heures
tulasne jusqu à ce qu ici qu'est ce que
tu racontes pour qui sait que tu fais
c'est un autre métier c'est ces
bonimenteurs quand tu baratine marathi
et si tu préfères c'est quoi le
le pitch de la caméra cachée que tu
préfères de toutes celles que tu as fait
toutes celles que j'ai fait je crois que
c'est celle que j'ai faite en père noël
un où les enfants venaient faire il
n'existait pas le père noël tu vois les
enfants venaient prendre la photo avec
le père noël et au fur et à mesure on a
mené les enfants dans la classe et quand
quand il arrivait je dormais way et d'un
là les enfants leur soit les enfants me
réveillait quelque en soit il piquait
les bombers et qu'elle dort il était
déçu les mômes non non non c'était très
très mignon aja les histoires comme je
sors le pote bien pascal riu travailler
à tf1 ouais mais pas que ça six
comédiens durant deux d'abord écoute on
va te faire une interview
quand on bosse à tf1
et après cette interview tu ne seras
plus pascal sellem quand on bosse et tf1
est ce qu'on le dit à sa famille à ses
amis ses enfants non je leur cash
on leur dit je suis désolée je suis bien
obligé de vivre des trucs comme ça je
leur dis que c'est grâce à tf1 qui sont
en train de manger de la viande à dakar
et ont dit à ses enfants tu sais papa
est en train de réaliser son rêve quand
on bosse à tf1 à ses enfants depuis
qu'il est rentré à dsk la cantine on
préfère s'asseoir entre bataille et
fontaine ou ppda avec claire chazal
canton d'axât tf1 mais si jamais foutu
les pieds tf1 à ces travaux c'est vrai
je suis jamais allé dans l'île même si
j'y suis allé une fois mais ils m'ont
demandé ma carte d'identité pour rentrer
du coup je suis pas je suis pas à
lesquin encore une carte quand on veut
c'est tf1 en a besoin de regarder
d'autres chaînes pendant son temps libre
bien sûr je regarde tout le temps
d'autres chaînes pendant mon terrible
pascal sérieusement quand on bosse et f1
est ce qu'on est obligé de faire des
émissions avec carole rousseau
c'est pas moi c'est laurent qui m'a
entraîné pour moi ça fait faire un
obligé de téléphoner sur bouygues
telecom non est-ce que des fois quand on
bossait tf1 on aimerait aller plus loin
on aimerait aller ailleurs
on a toujours envie d'aller ailleurs 1
quelle belle réplique max colard exemple
j'aimerais bien aller ailleurs aux
toilettes par hugo quand on bosse 202
s'était pas quand on bosse était fort -
est-ce qu'on prend un bon paquet de
thunes pascal
maintenant oui un an avant ce qui est
plus dur mais maintenant oui et on
laisse ses enfants regarder way to tout
c'est bien je crois qu'il faut miser une
carte discours je suis furieux parce que
c'est un poisson clown
non
absolument ça m'a pris deux heures et
demie pour avoir une carte tient non
mais maintenant j'étais sous le choc de
ce fait du sacré bon bon travail je sors
la nuit pour avoir une carte à 37
secondes et hop
ce sondage superbe salon dvd il est bien
puis à plein plein plein de bonus
ouais y'a les nice people que j'ai il a
fait des trucs super drôle dans son dvd
il a fait quoi
elle a fait un truc super drôle non
derrière des pôles bien ouais je crois
qu'on peut redonner le scoop est là une
blague en jeu parce que c'est en fait ça
me sert pas trop non pas le dit pas mais
je ne dis pas non je vais le dire en
fait quand on met le dvd les sept péchés
capitaux dans son lecteur
la première image qui arrive c'est ce
dvd ne convient pas à votre lecteur
ouais et la 3 6 7 5 secondes après trois
petits points non j'déconne
et là il ya des gens qui ont déjà été
voir
[Rires]
damas
parce que c'est un cadeau
[Musique]
péchés capitaux ah bon papa
alors notamment
[Musique]
à
maintenant on passe au bleu
[Applaudissements]
accueil or le blanc le blanc bonsoir un
sport leblanc vient de sortir une
compilation des conran shop selected by
aurore leblanc voilà on l'applaudît mon
ami bon vous connaissez le principe du
blind test c'est pas compliqué je veux
l'interprète et on peut dire d'ores et
déjà que c'est pascal sellem qui va
gagner
leblanc thèse ce soir mon ami pascal
sellem qui a passé pour moi s'il ya des
équipes d'abord est ce que les équipes
sont assez bien équilibré quoi nos deux
contador est signé ah oui 28 et celle m
contre le reste du monde et en tue bien
là
dolores vous passez la toi tu passes la
nique aux voilà très bien laurent baffie
pascal sellem contre le reste du monde
attention whore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sic et aux curieux
oui
dénouement de ces tueries
bon on entendu ce qu'il a dit pascal non
la litra peuvent souffler donc ça fait
un point pour l'équipe de laurent baffie
et pascal sellem et zéro point
pour le reste du monde quoi jean michel
moi je suis encore complètement ému mais
ce qui vient là c'est pour jean-michel
attention aux gens les voient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après
le reste du monde un célèbre baffie 1
attention whore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et un spa
non
[Musique]
la vidéo a tué les stars de la radio les
buggles bravo pascal sellem attention
whore
[Musique]
il
oh
je ne peux pas accepter parce que c'est
chez of the wall donc c'est vrai qu'à
jackson le point d'accepter l'accord
méline cours mais pas le point où on en
met partout non non non c'est vrai mais
bon
séverine a dit michael jackson oui mais
après il avait dit jackson pas en même
temps en temps
[Applaudissements]
n'y a pas de replay nom n'y a pas de
replay el hadid michael jackson bien
après jackson five donc nul 1 1 2 me
pour la 2.6 voit deux biplaces attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
attend il est dit waouh ici j'ai reconnu
george michael non c'est moi qui le dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la vie ensemble d'honneur
ça nous fait combien mais villa 2-2 oh
la la c'est très serré et serge tamoutoi
sergine un petit peu amoureux de leur
rsa a bien attention aux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
je vous demande de faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc ça fait 3 pour le reste du monde et
deux pour nos amis buffy et celle m
attention aurore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais il n'ya non temps séverine
ferrer a dit toxiques mais toiture dit
britney spears shakira tard je voulais
vous dire un truc ce pascal selene n'est
pas bons joueurs dont je dois vous
prévenir avant parce qu'il peut
s'énerver et un coup de boule s'est bien
passé avec les honneurs du banc tu as du
torse et les toxiques britney spears
allait plus le faire j'adore cette
chanson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces basses et serge khalfon catherine
barma 2
[Applaudissements]
va mourir
bon d'accord alors ces quatre pour le
reste du monde et deux pour les
champions du monde
attention n'en concentrez-vous parce que
voyez bien que là quand même c'est très
bagarre et nicolas attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien bien bien bien bien non c'est
octobre c'est au tour jeu que celle de
leur est là pensé avant akiba le point
serge dolores attention aux hommes
[Musique]
frash embêter la chaîne de librairies
pesci compliqué à deux interprètes
[Musique]
serge dolores
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors là
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu
comme des élections en algérie d'une
certaine façon oui on n'a pas su éviter
un vrai nom est bon alors je sais 5 3 5
pour eux soit pour eux ah là là non
attention j'adore la chanson qui vient
or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo de leurs biens et ben écoute
franchement y'a rien à dire je crois que
de leurs récents taire tout le monde
voilà après c'est bientôt le chacun pour
soi mais encore une chanson par équipes
attention en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à voir le magnéto juste pour pouvoir le
dire ensemble
est ce que c'est possible ça tu veux pas
la chanson magnéto juste pour nous voir
le dire ensemble avec de l'eau reste à
vous voulez vous voilà dix ans sans
s'arrêter
[Musique]
ils veulent se voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien je crois que vous êtes en train de
faire torcher maintenant mais belle
partie entre mons et ses fils de koudou
et épuisent jean-michel dans l'équipe ça
les a menés dès avec votre permission je
vous le laisse
ouais et je l'attends à vous préférez
sur le bateau sur bateau
oui oui il adore les mérous c'est gagné
les ghanéens discussion j'ai remplacé un
maquereau par une sirène
tu peux te mettre la main tenant nicolas
la bcge pour moi que tu veux pas changer
en place nicolas
non parce que maintenant c'est la fin du
par équipes attention le chacun pour sa
gueule ya public parce que la vie est
injuste mon gars bien attention je veux
l'interprète chacun pour soi oh
un marin
jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardon serge ouais non je trouve que de
l'oreille c'est génial parce que elle
gagne quand on a un peu honte de gagner
comme ça vraiment touchante ces
magnifiques vous êtes vraiment très
belle à voir
pensez vous pas gagné de touche entre
deux ou pas qu'elle est belle à voir
elle est belle à voir elle gagne pain
120 console et on travaille mon gardien
serge tu continues à mélanger t'es
gentille d'accord bon alors bébé oui
c'est de l'or et je suis désolé a donc
de leur s est maintenant il ya le super
banco
aurore
[Musique]
ah bon bain labeaume
au plus tard il y a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la quel manager quel manager tuer
nicolas c'est vraiment sans reculer
mccartney donnera il y est pour beaucoup
nicolas parce que j'étais notre show où
la même parcours annoncé pascal et moi
là dessus
bon ben alors là on est à 2 lo reste de
l'aurès là mais attends c'est fou cette
histoire a maintenant on passe au méga
vanko et qui va gagner d'après toi serge
serge or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là la richesse qui a gagné serge
serge bien là alors là évidemment
maintenant il ya l'ultra banco et voilà
et là maintenant si tu pouvais je sais
pas peut-être que non peut-être que oui
je sais pas on va voir
ouais y'a une after bien leur a rarement
été aussi grave que ce soir et que
maintenant s'ils donnent aures remporte
son 4e banco a je crois que la cge même
pas c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais
lu tio tu as raison c'est archers du
jamais vu obsolescentes et la banque
avait fait sauter la banque
elle prend notre salaire tour sur la je
demande vraiment au public de ne pas
souffler à vraiment sérieusement je
demande aux autres de chances que nous
leurs produits que pour répondre
taisez vous attention rang suis prête à
aller allons-y faut y aller
[Musique]
leur jeu
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais que serge khalfon passe un
gros plan de l'ardoisé
parce que ça c'est du jamais vu jamais
jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est énorme s'est passé ce soir merci
aurore je rappelle que le disque d'or de
conran shop sélective à monsieur vous
encombrer un morceau sur le générique de
fin
désigné moi même on a vécu quelque chose
de beau la magnifique dans l'histoire de
la mission dans le reste de leur s et
serge va quitter sa femme c'est moche
mais c'était notre vie qui commencera
beau serge
voilà je crois que c'était tout le monde
en parle
si tu as une belle émission tout cas pas
c'était tout le monde en parle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les armes chez fayard albert dupontel le
convoyeur sortie le 14 avril
séverine coeur des étoiles plein la tête
si on leur répond l'album s'appelle
séverine ferrer et il sort le 27 avril
le single s'appelle je me pardonne
nicolas rey courir à 30 ans c'est publié
au diable vauvert
jean michel cousteau merci
merci mon père le commandant s'est évité
à l'archipel
jean edouard lipa jésus lacaille avec
jean edouard lipa et marie laforêt à
l'espace pierre cardin à partir du 16
avril
les sosies vbck un endroit en meurent et
camilla chaque bolt de nos rêves chaplin
le single mountain bike h 15 chaînes
les caméras cachées les sept péchés
capitaux rendent en terre sans
frontières cuba le livre noir
coédition reporters sans frontières et
la découverte voilà c'était du monde en
parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine merci
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu